bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat on sait en cet
après-midi à la Haute Assemblée la
seconde lecture du projet loi de
finances rectificatif concernant le
budget de la Sécurité sociale c'est dans
ce texte et bien que l'on trouve les
allègements de charge patronales en lien
avec le pacte de responsabilité ce
budget rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale qui risque d'être retoqué une
nouvelle fois par le Sénat ça a été le
cas en premier lecture ça a été le cas
d'une façon générale pour tous les
textes budgétaires de cette session
parlementaire je vous rappelle également
que ce projet loi de finance
rectificatif sur la sécurité sociale et
bien comporte également des allègements
de charges concernant les emplois à
domicile en première lecture le Sénat
avait voté une diminution de ces charges
concernant tous les emplois à domicile
c'est un secteur qui connaît
actuellement des forts problèmes
d'emploi les emplois à domicile sont en
baisse
cet amendement de l'Assemblée nationale
avait été voté contre la vie du
gouvernement et à l'Assemblée nationale
et bien Marisol à limiter le champ de la
baisse des cotisations pour les emplois
à domicile elle la ministre la limitée
et bien aux emplois concernant des
gardes d'enfants concernant les aides
aux personnes
âgées ou aux personnes handicapées donc
on va voir ce qui va se passer cet
après-midi au Sénat je vous laisse
rejoindre l'hémicycle donc pour ce
projet loi de finance réfide
rectificatif autour de la sécurité
sociale
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture de financement rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale pour 2014 dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Marisol Touraine ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé madame
la ministre vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je reviens vers vous aujourd'hui devant
vous moins d'une semaine après le rejet
de la première partie du projet de loi
de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale par
votre assemblée la situation il faut le
dire et donc à ses proches de celle dans
laquelle nous étions il y a une semaine
puisque l'Assemblée nationale a confirmé
son vote de première lecture hier en
votant le texte qu'elle avait adopté
sans en modifier les orientations ni les
équilibres mais avec toutefois quelques
modifications sur lesquelles je
reviendrai
je veux tout d'abord rappeler très
brièvement les orientations de ce texte
qui conduisent le gouvernement a proposé
aujourd'hui une démarche résolue en
faveur de la croissance et de l'emploi
et c'est parce que la démarche du
gouvernement est résolue que le
gouvernement demande à votre à votre
assemblée de l'adopter une orientation
en faveur de l'emploi assumez comme tel
et revendiquée comme tel à travers un
effort inédit de baisse de prélèvement
sur le travail en direction des
entreprises parce que cet effort n'est
pas un cadeau comme je l'entends parfois
et encore moins un cadeau aux
organisations patronales nous avons
accepté un amendement de l'Assemblée
nationale qui permet de limiter les
éventuelles effets d'aubaine dans
certains secteurs et nous avons par
ailleurs soutenu un amendement qui
permet aux partenaires sociaux de se
saisir de l'usage qui sera fait de ces
allègements en inscrivant cette question
dans le champ de la négociation annuelle
obligatoire
le Gouvernement présente ce texte en
affirmant sa volonté constante de
justice sociale qui se retrouvent aussi
bien dans les mesures d'économie que
nous prenons que dans les mesures prises
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
à bas revenus je veux d'abord rappeler
que les mesures de gel dont on a
beaucoup parlé depuis la présentation
initiale de ce texte ne touche
aujourd'hui ni les petites retraites ni
la location de logements familial et que
les économies sur l'assurance maladie
qui dans ce texte se traduisent par des
décisions concernant la recommandation
temporaire d'utilisation pour certains
médicaments ou pour les conséquences qui
sont tirées de la situation de 2013 que
donc les économies qui sont proposées
pour l'assurance maladie ne remettent en
aucun cas le niveau de la protection qui
est proposé des panneaux concitoyens
donc des mesures
déconnales est revenue les plus modestes
et d'autre part je veux rappeler que
dans ce texte figure des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat en faveur des ménages à
bas revenu avec notamment ou à faible
revenu avec notamment l'exonération de
cotisation salariale en faveur des
basses à l'air mon collègue Christian
Heckert pourrait pourra rappeler sans
doute que ce texte s'appréhende de
manière conjointe avec le projet de loi
de finances rectificative qui comporte
des mesures en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
à travers la diminution d'impôts qui va
concerner un nombre important de nos
concitoyens et donc il y a là une
démarche cohérente globale de notre part
la politique qui est la nôtre et qui est
celle du rétablissement des comptes doit
nous permettre de réduire les déficits
de la Sécurité sociale et partant de
maintenir de garantir un haut niveau de
protection sociale de ce point de vue là
par rapport au texte qui vous a été
soumis la semaine dernière
quels sont les évolutions la principale
modification introduite hier par
l'Assemblée nationale concerne le sujet
des services à domicile je sais que
c'est une question qui a été portée ici
même et qui donc doit faire l'objet d'un
large consensus l'amendement adopté hier
permet de doubler la déduction
forfaitaire pour les particuliers
employeurs dans certains cas certains
cas qui permettent de cibler ses
avantages sur des personnes qui
présentent des besoins sociaux
importants c'est ainsi que nous
considérons collectivement qu'un effort
peut être fait et doit être fait en
faveur de la garde d'enfant de l'aide
aux personnes âgées en voie de perte
d'autonomie en particulier il ne serait
pas souhaitable d'avoir une démarche
globale indiffenciée alors même que
certaines personnes bénéficiant des
avantages ainsi procurés n'en aurait pas
besoin
l'amendement adopté hier répond je crois
à vos objectifs de soutien à l'emploi
sur des besoins sociaux tout en étant
respectueux des équilibres des finances
publiques et c'est pourquoi j'espère que
vous lui réserverez un accueil favorable
au-delà le texte qui vous est présenté
ne comporte pas de modifications
substantielle par rapport au test que
vous exavez examinez la semaine dernière
je ne reviens donc pas sur la démarche
d'ensemble qui est la nôtre je l'ai
rappelé d'un mot c'est une mobilisation
collective qui doit nous rassembler tous
en faveur de la croissance en faveur de
l'emploi et qui doit nous permettre de
montrer que le cap politique suivi et
cohérent et que nous sommes tous
rassemblés pour faire gagner notre
économie et nos concitoyens dans la
compétition internationale merci à vous
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Christian heckerte secrétaire
d'État chargé du budget
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs vous avez
examiné la semaine dernière le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale et votre examen c'est
soldé par un rejet
le contenu de ce texte a été
parfaitement détaillé en commission et
en première lecture par votre rapporteur
aussi n'est-il pas indispensable d'en
présenter de manière approfondie les
articles que vous connaissez et que vous
avez en partie adoptée
je souhaite néanmoins rappeler la
démarche globale dans laquelle s'inscrit
le texte il s'agit d'abord vous le savez
de renforcer la croissance au moyen du
soutien à l'emploi d'une part et à la
compétitivité des entreprises d'autre
part
pour atteindre cet objectif notre
premier levier d'action et de redonner
les marges et la visibilité nécessaire
au projet des entreprises
c'est le sens de la nouvelle baisse du
coût du travail ciblé sur les basses à
l'air jusqu'à 1,6 fois le SMIC c'est
aussi pour cela que les cotisations
personnelles des travailleurs
indépendants et des exploitants
agricoles seront réduites dans le cadre
d'une exonération qui concernera 90% des
artisans et commerçants et environ 95%
des non salariés agricoles
notre deuxième levier d'action est
d'aléger la fiscalité des entreprises
pesant sur la production et ce afin de
soutenir l'investissement
c'est donc c'est donc dans cet objectif
que nous vous proposons d'agir sur la
contribution sociale de solidarité des
sociétés la C3S
impôts particulièrement décrié comme
anti-économique payé par les entreprises
à proportion de leur chiffre d'affaires
et qui pénalise principalement le
secteur industriel qui est au cœur de
nos préoccupations
le gouvernement propose de réduire la
C3S dès 2015 avec une suppression prévue
pour toutes les entreprises à horizon
2017 un abattement permettra aux deux
tiers des 300 000 redevables d'être
totalement exonéré dès 2015
je précise enfin que l'impact sur la
sécurité sociale des différentes mesures
du PLF RSS 2014 sera intégralement
compensé selon des modalités qui seront
définies dans les lois financières pour
cette compensation aura un impact sur
les finances de l'État il faut en être
conscient mais c'est un effort
nécessaire qui est à la mesure de notre
engagement en faveur de l'investissement
et de la compétitivité des entreprises
enfin
et c'est un sujet qui vous tient à cœur
les députés ont souhaité reprendre dans
une version plus ciblée en direction des
publics qui en ont le plus besoin le
souci que vous aviez exprimé d'un geste
en direction des particuliers employeurs
notamment en matière de garde d'enfant
lorsque l'âge de ceci ne permet pas de
bénéficier d'aide des caisses
d'allocations familiales et en direction
de certaines personnes fragiles qui
n'ont pas droit aujourd'hui aux aides
notamment parce que nous ne sont pas
reconnus comme suffisamment dépendants
c'est une démarche ciblée plus proche de
ce qui les raisonnable de supporter pour
nos finances publiques qu'une hausse
généralisée de l'abattement mais c'est
néanmoins une modification constructive
à laquelle vous serez sensible
en second lieu ces baisses de
prélèvement sont financés comme le
gouvernement s'y est engagé par la
maîtrise concomitante des finances
publiques je souhaite à cet égard
rappeler que depuis 2012 la progression
de la dépense publique est tout à fait
maîtrisée des mesures adoptées pour 2013
ont permis d'obtenir des résultats
importants la dette publique a augmenté
en valeur de 2% sont plus bas niveau
depuis 1998
vous avez déjà débattu la semaine
dernière des économies qui seront
réalisées sur les dépenses de l'État
dans le cadre du débat d'orientation des
finances publiques chacun a pu prendre
la mesure de l'ampleur de l'effort prévu
mais aussi constaté que la maîtrise de
la dépense préservée au sein du budget
de l'État les moyens nécessaires
au financement des priorités du
gouvernement il s'agit de faire des
choix d'agir sur les marges pour
réaliser des économies sans remettre en
cause le champ d'action de l'État n'y
réduire la qualité du service public ni
renoncer à notre modèle social
à cet égard il nous faut insister sur la
nécessité des économies prévues dans la
sphère sociale les économies ne sont
jamais faciles à mettre en oeuvre mais
celle que nous vous proposons sont
équilibrés puisque les prestations des
plus modestes sont largement ou
totalement préservés
en outre ces mesures d'économies ne
doivent pas faire oublier les mesures en
faveur des assurés que nous portons je
pense par exemple à la revalorisation du
plan pauvreté ou à la revalorisation
exceptionnelle du minimum vieillesse
un travail de fond a été conduit avec la
majorité parlementaire sur l'ensemble du
Pacte pour aménager certaines mesures
pour aboutir à un meilleur équilibre et
renforcer la cohérence de l'ensemble
avec les mesures prises en faveur des
plus modestes
enfin le texte a été modifié en première
lecture pour en retirer plusieurs
mesures d'économies proposées le
gouvernement a répondu à ses amendements
il ne s'agit pas pour autant de remettre
en cause l'effort les économies qui ne
seront plus faites au moyen de tel ou
telle mesure sont effectuées par
d'autres moyens dans le cadre d'une
poursuite de dialogue avec le Parlement
enfin un élément de l'équilibre du pacte
en apparence extérieure à ce texte en
constitue pourtant une condition
essentielle je veux bien entendu parler
des contreparties
le Premier ministre l'a rappelé lors de
la clôture de la conférence sociale
l'effort consenti par la puissance
publique et sans précédent et il
implique légitimement des contreparties
pour l'emploi
c'est un principe que le gouvernement
s'est fixé à l'engagement de l'État doit
correspondre un engagement de tous en
faveur de l'emploi
tout l'enjeu est alors de se laisser la
possibilité de réévaluer les efforts de
l'État à l'aune de ceux des entreprises
le gouvernement souhaite ainsi mettre en
place un dispositif de suivi du pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité afin de
garantir que les sommes ainsi perçues
par les entreprises sont effectivement
affectées à l'emploi et à
l'investissement sur ce point encore le
président de la République est le
premier ministre ont été clairs la
semaine dernière pour mieux suivre les
aides aux entreprises les missions du
comité de suivi du cice seront élargies
afin de disposer d'un outil d'évaluation
pérenne de l'usage des aides et de leur
efficacité
dans chaque branche les partenaires
sociaux seront chargés de s'assurer de
la bonne affectation des marges de
manœuvre ainsi dégagées
vous avez adopté en première lecture
administrative du rapporteur général un
amendement pour que le thème de l'emploi
des aides aux entreprises figurent parmi
les thèmes de la négociation annuelle
obligatoire au niveau des entreprises
c'est un bon moyen de s'assurer que le
pacte soit prise en compte dans les
orientations stratégiques de
l'entreprise
comme vous le savez
et j'y tiens tout particulièrement si
les deux textes financiers de cet été
trace bien les perspectives jusqu'en
il ne contiennent que les mesures 2014
et 2015
en effet il est indispensable de pouvoir
s'assurer que les entreprises assumeront
bien la contrepartie de l'effort du
gouvernement
après cette première étape un bilan
devra être fait et il conditionnera la
poursuite de leur mise en œuvre des
mesures d'une pacte
c'est une garantie que nous nous donnons
c'est la condition de la réciprocité et
en fin de compte de l'efficacité de
l'effort consenti par la puissance
publique
un important travail de fond a été
conduit avec la majorité parlementaire
et les partenaires pour mettre au point
ce dispositif il garantit l'équilibre du
pacte et il renforce la légitimité aux
yeux de tous
car c'est bien là que se joue aussi le
pacte de responsabilité et de solidarité
dans sa capacité à rassembler à faire
dialoguer les acteurs économiques et
sociaux à dépasser l'écrivage et à créer
une dynamique d'échange et de
mobilisation collective au service de
l'emploi c'est le défi que nous devons
relever cette année et il est
déterminant pour l'avenir de notre pays
parce que ce sont tous les Français qui
ont à y gagner
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Yves Daudigny rapportant
général de la commission des affaires
sociales
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre un président de la
commission mes chers collègues nous
sommes saisis en nouvelle lecture du
projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 après son passage à
l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture le projet de loi comporté 21
articles 5 articles additionnels étant
venu compléter les 16 articles du texte
initial pour l'essentiel et cela a été
prévisible l'Assemblée nationale a
repris le texte ici de ces travaux de
première lecture après son rejet par
notre assemblée le 16 juillet dernier et
l'échec de la commission mixte paritaire
le 17 juillet
ainsi que nous y invite l'article
liminaire qui retrace les soldes de
l'ensemble de nos comptes publics le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale doit
être replacée avec le projet de loi de
finance rectificatif dans le contexte
plus global dans lequel il s'inscrit ce
contexte c'est une croissance économique
atone chômage dramatiquement élevé et
des comptes publics structurellement
déséquilibrées pour y apporter une
réponse le projet de loi traduit les
engagements pris par le Président de la
République dans le cadre du pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité déclinés
dans différents textes financiers
présents et à venir le mot d'ordre du
pack de responsabilité c'est la
confiance c'est au nom de cette
confiance que nous devons refuser l'idée
par exemple de conditionnalités strictes
c'est l'idée de travailler ensemble de
conjuguer les efforts de l'État des
ménages et des entreprises pour trouver
un nouvel élan et redonner des
perspectives à notre économie et
peut-être au-delà un autre société
gagnée par la morosité et même parfois
par le fatalisme alors qu'elle dispose
nous le savons de vrais atouts
pour ce faire comme je le soulignais
déjà en première lecture le projet de
loi se décline dans un triptyque qui
forme un tout cohérent le soutien à la
consommation des ménages modestes le
soutien à la compétitivité des
entreprises et une trajectoire de
redressement des comptes publics le
soutien au ménage tout d'abord c'est
l'engagement pris après les efforts
récents de ne plus augmenter les
prélèvements des classes moyennes de
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des bas
salaires et d'accroître la solidarité
envers les plus fragiles je rappelle
ainsi que les minimas sociaux ne sont
pas concernés par le gel de prestation
et c'est bien contraire dans un contexte
difficile l'effort envers les plus
fragiles n'est pas seulement préserver
il est accru
l'article premier du projet via la
baisse des cotisations salariales
introduit une progressivité des
prélèvements salariaux et redonnera du
salaire net ou salarié mais aussi aux
fonctionnaires dont le revenu se situe à
proximité du SMIC c'était fort qui
représente 2,5 milliards d'euros
injectés dans le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages se combinent avec l'aménagement
du barème de l'impôt sur le revenu porté
par le collectif budgétaire le soutien à
la compétitivité des entreprises ensuite
dans un climat économique difficile le
pacte vise à soutenir l'investissement
des entreprises à améliorer leur
compétitivité à l'export ou au moment
précis où nous attendons la reprise de
la croissance portée par la demande
mondiale ce volet central du pacte passe
par une amplification du mécanisme de la
réduction dégressive de cotisations
patronales sur les bas salaires afin de
parvenir à niveau de 0 charge
URSSAF pour le SMIC à compter du premier
janvier 2015 il a instaure également un
tour réduit de cotisations familiale sur
les basses salaires il prévoit en fin de
réduire les cotisations d'allocations
familiales et travailleurs indépendants
agricoles et non agricoles pour les bas
revenus l'allègement des charges des
entreprises passe aussi par la
suppression progressive d'ici à 2017 de
la C3S au total les articles 2 et 3 du
projet de loi représente un effort de
6,5 milliards d'euros en 2015
la trajectoire globale de redressement
des finances publiques en fin dans le
cadre fixé par le programme de stabilité
2014-2017 le pacte programme une
réduction ambitieuse notre déficit avec
un plan d'économie de 50 milliards
d'euros sur la période notre système de
protection sociale devra prendre sa part
soit 21 milliards d'euros 42% à hauteur
de son poids dans les dépenses publiques
pour garantir l'avenir de ce système qui
a bien joué son rôle dans la crise il
faut en redresser les équilibres
financiers et je voudrais en dire un mot
je rappelle tout d'abord que d'après la
loi de programmation en cours votée fin
2012 le retour à l'équilibre des comptes
sociaux toutes administration sécurité
sociale confondues étaient prévus en
2014 nous avons consenti pour cela un
effort de maîtrise et dépenses et de
remise à niveau des recettes or si les
objectifs de dépenses ont été tenus
notamment landame landame pour la
quatrième année consécutive les recettes
en raison d'une croissance faible non
pas été au rendez-vous les déficits
sociaux s'élevant à 12,5 milliards
d'euros pour 2014 le projet de loi
dégrade par conséquent la prévision de
soldes des régimes obligatoires de base
à -10,1 milliards d'euros compte 9,8
prévus en loi de financement pour 2014
pour sa part le solde du régime général
avec 9,8 milliards d'euros passe sous la
barre symbolique des 10 milliards ce
solde est la double conséquence de 1,7
milliards de mois en volume sur les
recettes et de 1,4 milliards de moins en
volume sur les dépenses c'est très
vision de l'objectif de dépenses et du
pour l'essentiel ou rebasage de la dame
l'article 9 prévoit le gel du montant
des pensions de retraite de base qui
doivent normalement faire l'objet d'une
revalorisation 1er octobre prochain le
montant des économies réalisées
représenterait en année pleine près d'un
milliard d'euros soit en moyenne 11
euros par mois et par retraité je
rappelle que près de la moitié des
retraités soit 6,5 millions de personnes
ne seront pas concernés par ce gel dans
la mesure où leur pension est inférieure
à 1200 euros brut par mois le gel des
prestations certes je l'ai déjà dit
peut-être discuter mais il est la moins
mauvaise des solutions par rapport à des
dans les prestations et dans une période
de faible inflation et cela a déjà été
souligné il demande certes des efforts
au bénéficiaires mais ne portent nous
l'avons dit que sur la moitié de la
population concernée sur le périmètre
des ménages et pour le sol PLF RSS je
l'avais déjà indiqué les 935 millions
d'euros de gel des pensions en 2015 sont
à comparer avec les 2,5 milliards
d'euros de pouvoir d'achat rendu aux
actifs les plus modestes sans prise en
compte des mesures fiscales inscrites
dans le collectif budgétaire en faveur
des ménages les plus modestes en
première lecture l'Assemblée nationale
avait adopté 5 articles additionnels
insérer suite un amendement du
Gouvernement l'article 9 bis propose
d'élargir le champ de la recommandation
temporaire d'utilisation RTU en
autorisant l'usage de médicaments hors
de leur autorisation de mise sur le
marché dès lors qu'il n'existe pas de
spécialités possédant la même substance
active le même dosage et la même forme
pharmaceutique les articles 9 ter 9
sexistes comportent diverses mesures
relatives ou complémentaires santé je ne
les reprendrai pas en nouvelle lecture
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté pour
l'essentiel des amendements
rédactionnels ou de coordination à
l'article 2 elle a adopté un amendement
relatif à la réduction forfaitaire de
cotisations applicable aux particuliers
employeurs elle a porté cette réduction
à 1,5 euros pour les services de garde
d'enfant les services aux personnes
âgées dépendantes et aux personnes
handicapées cette disposition voisine
moins inspirée de celles que votre
commission des affaires sociales avaient
proposé lors de l'examen du texte le
Sénat sans être néanmoins tout à fait
comparable je ne peux me féliciter tout
d'abord de cette évolution qui a été
donc rendue possible à l'Assemblée
nationale après le blocage ici au Sénat
dans ce dossier des particuliers
employeurs deux logiques sont à l'oeuvre
une logique de soutien au public fragile
d'une part qui est largement satisfaite
par l'amendement adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale dans le temps des présidents
des précisions que le gouvernement
apportera par décret mais une autre
logique de reconquête de l'emploi
déclaré et de développement de l'emploi
à domicile d'autre part sur ce point
l'amendement ne répond que partiellement
aux objectifs émettent en place un
dispositif qui paraît complexe comment
contrôler en effet l'écart de réduction
de cotisation entre la garde d'enfants
et le soutien scolaire à ces mêmes
enfants ou encore l'entretien du
domicile de cette même famille
il faudra faire entrer dans l'outil de
déclaration de cotisation des éléments
du contrat de travail qui n'y figure pas
jusqu'à présent je suis cependant
favorable je le dis sont très claires à
l'exclusion de la niche sociale mais
aussi de la niche fiscale des emplois
cités par monsieur le ministre Christian
Hecker à l'appui de son argumentation
contre l'amendement du Sénat la semaine
dernière et même si je le dis en
souriant nous ne pensons pas que les
professeurs de claquettes parce qu'ils
avaient été cités soit les gens parmi
les emplois à domicile je répète bien
favorable à l'exclusion des niches aussi
bien sociales que fiscal de ces emplois
aussi il est vraisemblable que la
disposition adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale et que je soutiens donc madame
le ministre je réponds à la question que
vous avez posé tout à l'heure à vocation
à être temporaire il est souhaitable que
le gouvernement engage puisque c'est du
domaine supplémentaires un travail sur
les emplois éligibles à la déduction
forfaitaire en vend peut-être d'unifier
son taux si l'on considère qu'un emploi
donné ne doit pas bénéficier du soutien
public pourquoi le faire bénéficier de
la réduction surfetter fut-elle de
moitié voilà madame monsieur les
ministres collègues quelques
observations que je souhaitais vous
livrer sur ce sujet des emplois à
domicile pour l'essentiel les autres
mesures portées par ce texte sont bien
connus elles sont discutées depuis plus
de six mois le temps est venu de les
concrétiser et de traduire dans le droit
ces orientations lors de la réunion de
la commission des affaires sociales ce
matin j'avais proposé à celle-ci
d'émettre un avis favorable au projet de
loi dans la rédaction
issue de la nouvelle lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale à la suite d'un
partage des voix la commission n'a pas
adopté les conclusions que je lui
proposais je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard roche
pour le groupe
udi UC
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Monsieur
je voudrais
TER d'État madame la Présidente de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègue comme vous le savez nous
avons été très déçu et attristé de la
manière dont la discussion s'est
déroulée en première lecture sur ce
texte
comme vous le savez nous l'abordions
sans dogmatisme ni a priori avec un
esprit d'ouverture dont nous espérions
qu'il transcende les clivages
politiciens notre hotte assemblée avait
notamment fait adopté le doublement de
la réduction de cotisations par heure
d'emploi a déclaré à domicile nous
étions très attachés à cet amendement
parce qu'un plan domicile est un secteur
d'avenir qui doit être soutenu il avait
valeur en plus symbolique
en effet après la suppression des
aménagements fiscaux dont jouissez les
particuliers employeurs à savoir
l'abattement de 15 points sur les
cotisations patronales supprimer le 1er
janvier 2012 et le forfait supprimer
l'huile 1er janvier 2013 et malgré
l'instauration d'une réduction de
cotisation de 75 centimes par heure
déclarée le nombre d'heures déclarées
ABC de 7% en 2013 soit une perte d'au
moins 16000 équivalent en plein après
une première baisse d'au moins 12000
équivalentes en plein en 2012 en deux
ans le nombre de particuliers de
particuliers employeurs a reculé de
3,2%. le nombre d'heures déclarés a
chuté de
6,1%. ce volet touche 30 à 40 000
personnes or à chacune de ces mesures
nous avions tiré à son aide à l'âme pour
dire que toucher à ce régime fiscal
menacerait l'emploi à domicile et tout
le Moyen l'emploi déclaré parce que
infinie la perte d'emploi déclaré est
une perte de cotisations estimé à 120
millions d'euros par an nous pouvons
donc soutenir l'amendement de notre
rapporteur idodéni dont je salue au
passage l'excellence du travail et
l'abnégation un amendement qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité au Sénat et le
gouvernement au lieu de respecter notre
vote et ce consensus de bon sens n'a
rien trouvé de mieux que nous savoter
sur les recettes en vote bloqué avec ce
gant de libération pour revenir à son
texte initial dans ces conditions alors
que nous avions l'intention de voter les
recettes oui monsieur le secrétaire
d'État l'autre jour vous aviez dit qu'on
était on avait un peu menti
mais on avait bien l'intention de voter
des recettes nous avons été contraints
de nous y opposer le débat a ainsi
tourné court
madame la ministre puisque ce débat n'a
pas eu en première lecture pourquoi
aurait-il eu davantage en nouvelle
lecture notre position sur ce texte est
connue oui nous étions prêt à voter la
partie recette du plfs plfrs parce que
nous soutenons les baisses de charge sur
les basses salaires baisse de charge
salariale pour donner du pouvoir d'achat
et surtout baisse de charge patronale
pour redynamiser la compétitivité de nos
entreprises ce volet-là du pacte
responsabilité nous ne pouvions donc que
le soutenir en revanche vos options de
financement restent pour le moins
évasives le résultat est un PDF RSS
totalement déséquilibré car face aux 9
milliards de manquent à gagner pour la
sécu en 2015 que nous proposez-vous ils
seront compensés c'est la seule étude la
seule certitude que nous ayons puisque
le corps de la sécurité sociale l'impose
pour l'instant la seule mesure concrète
proposée par le gouvernement dans le
présenter les RSS et le gel des pensions
de retraite à partir de 1200 euros brut
puis celle des allocations familiales en
ces deux mesures ne devrait rapporter
que 1,3 milliards elles sont
disproportion avec les besoins et de
plus elles sont discutables sur le plan
éthique car il n'est pas juste de faire
contribuer ainsi les plus modestes
pour le reste on évolue dans le flou
plutôt tal le gouvernement s'est engagé
à ne plus toucher à la fiscalité le plan
repose donc sur 50 milliards d'économies
réalisées par l'ensemble des
administrations publiques 18 milliards
de par l'État on entend toujours les
informations complémentaires pour
pouvoir en juger 11 milliards pour les
collectivités comment ah ben ça on le
devine avec une baisse des tentations
globale de fonctionnement grâce à la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
je ne reviens pas sur le reste à charge
pour la sécurité sociale
la représentation nationale a droit à
plus d'informations nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que vous entreteniez plus
longtemps le flou sur vos options
budgétaires pour ne pas avoir le courage
de poser ouvertement la véritable
question sur laquelle nous venons sans
cesse celle de la fiscalisation par la
TVA ou la CSG du financement de la
protection sociale car c'est là à mon
avis problème de fond dans ces
conditions et enfin de ne pas perdre
davantage de temps parlementaire ou les
compris le groupe udius restera sur sa
position initiale nous voterons la
partie recette d'autant plus que la
madema phare de notre rapporteur ISO
Denis votèrent l'unanimité par notre
hotte assemblée a été en partie repris
et un peu modifiée mais il doit dignit
un appareil tout à l'heure pour voter ce
pdf RSS
pour interdire je m'excuse elle était
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale mais
avec des modifications mais qui
préservent l'essentiel
infinie nous ne pourrons pas voter ce
PLFSS pour 2014 devant autant des
précisions sur les économies à faire et
devant l'absence d'ouverture vers une
fiscalisation partielle par la CSG et
surtout par la TVA sociale merci de
votre attention
merci monsieur le sénateur pour le
groupe CR c'est la parole est à Monsieur
Dominique vatran
monsieur le madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le secrétaire
d'État mes chers collègues en recourant
une seconde délibération couplée à un
vote bloqué vous avez fait la
démonstration de la faiblesse du
gouvernement sur le fond comme sur la
forme sur la procédure parlementaire
comme sur le contenu même de ce projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale vous êtes montré
incapable d'apporter des solutions
permettant de réunir autour de vous la
gauche dans son ensemble
en réponse à mon intervention générale
vous m'aviez indiqué madame la ministre
qui ne suffisait pas de claquer les
doigts pour créer des emplois et
financer notre système de protection
sociale cela fait plus de 20 ans que des
allègements massifs de cotisation
sociale sont consenties plus de 20 ans
que les gouvernements successifs
génèrent de la dette sociale pour
soi-disant soutenir de l'emploi mais
pour quel résultat aucun chiffre en
réalité ne permet de prouver clairement
que ce type de mesure permet de créer
des emplois alors je vous retourne la
question madame la ministre sur quelles
études d'impact vous font des vous pour
affirmer que les mesures d'allègement de
cotisation patronales contenu dans ce
projet de loi permettront d'améliorer la
situation économique de notre pays quant
aux mesures de compensation pourtant
obligatoire vous êtes toujours dans
l'incapacité de nous dire comment elles
seront organisées une chose est sûre ces
mesures seront fiscales elles pèseront
sur les familles et le ménage puisque
votre objectif est de réduire les
prélèvements supportés par les
entreprises si je comprends donc votre
gêne à les annoncer publiquement je ne
peux que dénoncer ce manque de
considération envers les parlementaires
de la même manière vous avez refusé de
nous dire qu'elle serait les contraintes
ou tout du moins les contreparties à la
charge des entreprises pour pouvoir
prétendre au bénéfices de ces
exonérations ces silences gardaient
alors que vous nous avez toujours pas
clairement expliqué comment des mesures
de réduction de cotisation sociale pour
2015 pouvait être présente dans un
projet de loi financement rectificatif
pour 2014 nous ont conduit à voter
contre les recettes que vous nous
proposiez j'observe que nous n'avons pas
été isolé puisque les sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe EUROPE écologique
les Verts se sont abstenus et qu'il vous
aura manqué la voix de deux sénateurs
socialistes qui c'est un fait notable
aussi voté contre votre projet et du
rapporteur lui-même qui a préféré ne pas
prendre par au ventre au vote je vois
danser cette situation la traduction
d'un mécontentement grandissant un la
majorité sénatoriale quand de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle votre projet est
plutôt attirer la bienveillance du
groupe udi qui dès la commission des
affaires sociales avait annoncé vouloir
adopter les recettes pour examiner les
descentes des dépenses et de l'UMP qui
avait annoncé vouloir s'abstenir et pour
cause vos réductions de cotisations
sociales ne diffèrent pas réellement du
plan massif d'exonération mise en place
par François Fillon de ce fait et on l'a
vu dans les débats la droite ne nous
vous reproche plus grand chose si ce
n'est de ne pas les plus vite et plus
loin dans les politiques austéritaires
et pourtant malgré ce soutien de la
droite et du centre vous avez fait le
choix d'imposer au Sénat une seconde
délibération destinées à revenir
notamment
sur un amendement adopté à l'unanimité
tout cela pour faire votre volte-face à
l'Assemblée nationale quelques jours
plus tard permettez-moi de vous dire
combien certains propos tenus ici par
monsieur Eckert paresse nous paraissent
avec ce recul encore plus maîtrisant à
l'issue de nos débats nous avions été
nombreux et nombreux à nous interroger
sur les motifs qui vous ont conduit un
tel comportement j'y vois pour ma part
votre crainte de devoir publiquement
afficher le soutien même relatif de la
droite sénatoriale à votre projet de loi
en plus de celui déjà exprimé par le
MEDEF j'y vois aussi la crainte de
devoir vous expliquer plus en avant sur
l'article 7 qui nouvelle fois comme vous
l'aviez fait dans votre réforme des
retraites prévoit de geler les pensions
au point de faire baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités cette mesure est
contestée par tout le monde ou presque
mais vous persistez encore chacun des
groupes parlementaires se compose notre
Haute Assemblée exception faite du
groupe socialiste ont déposé un
amendement de suppression de cette
mesure qui disons-le clairement est
injuste le recours à cette seconde
délibération ce vote bloqué nous
apparaît donc être une fuite en avant de
même qui est une fuite en avant vers
toujours plus de libéralisme la
politique que vous entendez mettre en
œuvre alors que tout le monde s'accorde
à dire que le gel des prestations
sociales initialement prévues et celui
maintenu des retraites produira un effet
récessif accentuellement même certaines
dépenses sociales vous persistez
oubliant au passage au-delà des chiffres
et statistiques c'est de la vie de nos
concitoyens du fonctionnement des
hôpitaux de notre protection sociale et
notre système de soins dont il s'agit
cette fuite en avant madame monsieur le
ministre nous l'a refusons depuis 2012
élection de François Hollande à la
présidence de la République les
sénatrices et sénateurs communistes
républicains citoyens demeure fidèle à
leurs engagements nous continuons à
réaffirmer que nous sommes disposés à
soutenir le gouvernement dès lors qu'il
mettra en œuvre une politique résolument
sociale et solidaire qui au lieu de
faire pression sur les salariés
proposeraient une meilleure et juste
réparistes très partition des richesses
cela passe selon nous entre autres par
la modulation des exonérations de
cotisations sociales en fonction de la
politique salariale et d'emploi des
entreprises ce serait juste et bénéfique
pour les contes de la sécurité sociale
cela passe aussi par une nécessaire
réorientation de l'argent au service de
l'économie réelle et des besoins humains
c'est pourquoi nous proposons entre
autres aussi de taxer les revenus
financiers spéculatifs qui ne servent
pas l'économie et détruisent des emplois
accepterez-vous enfin la discussion sur
ces nouvelles recettes à chercher dans
la sphère financière là où passe trop
d'argent aujourd'hui c'est à ce chantier
que vous devriez vous atteler
plutôt qu'à l'approvrissement la
sécurité sociale en particulier de la
branche famille ou au report à
répétition de la prise en charge de
l'autonomie mais en l'état et sans aucun
signe de votre part face à une politique
sans rupture avec la majorité précédente
et plus grave encore dangereuse les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe CRC
n'auront d'autres choix que de rejeter
ce projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
merci monsieur le sénateur pour le
groupe RD sol la parole est à madame
Anne-Marie Escoffier
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur général cher
collègues je voudrais me féliciter de la
qualité du débat qui a eu lieu ici au
Sénat conjugué avec celui de l'Assemblée
nationale même si ensemble nous ne
sommes pas parvenus à rapprocher tous
les points de vue le texte que nous
allons voter dans un instant ne
satisfait pas tous les membres du groupe
RDSE au nom duquel je m'exprime cet
après-midi mon excellent collègue
Gilbert Barbier membre de la commission
des affaires sociales a eu l'occasion au
cours des précédents débats de dire les
difficultés auxquelles ce RT les
dispositions envisagées l'hypothèse
d'une trop forte croissance 1%
paraissait trop optimiste le retard
apporté à la mise en oeuvre des
allègements de cotisation salariale pour
les salariés les moins rémunérés ainsi
que la baisse des cotisations sociales
des employeurs et travailleurs
indépendants le gel de la revalorisation
de certaines retraites mais je voudrais
au nom du plus grand nombre des miens
soulignait que malgré ses imperfections
en dépit du rejet de plusieurs
amendements dont nous pensions qu'ils
allaient dans le bon sens nous
soutiendrons un texte qui répond à
l'engagement du président de la
République à celui de tout le
gouvernement de mettre en œuvre avec
détermination le pacte de responsabilité
et de solidarité
dans le contexte qui est celui de la
France d'aujourd'hui qui pourrait
soutenir que l'investissement l'emploi
et le pouvoir d'achat des ménages n'est
pas une absolue priorité
le projet de loi de financement de
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale ces
données ces priorités relancer le
pouvoir d'achat en réduisant de façon
dégressive les cotisations salariales
favoriser l'emploi en utilisant
différents leviers notamment la légende
sur les basses à l'air la réduction des
taux de cotisation des allocations
familiales et permettre ainsi de créer
de nouveaux emplois l'objectif de 30000
emplois supplémentaires en 2015
60000 en 2016 n'est pas irréaliste si
chacun s'attache et monsieur le ministre
l'a dit à respecter l'esprit et la
lettre des nouvelles dispositions
notamment à travers les contreparties
troisième priorité la relance de la
croissance une relance qui doit passer
par un retour à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises la suppression progressive
de la contribution sociale de solidarité
des sociétés la C3S est au cœur du pacte
de responsabilité et de solidarité la
première étape va intervenir dès le 1er
janvier 2015
libérante ainsi essentiellement les
petites et très petites entreprises d'un
assujettissement à la C3S qui menaçait
leur équilibre avec notre rapporteur je
veux donc saluer les conditions qui
permettent aujourd'hui de faire valoir
un texte qui s'est attaché à trouver les
voies d'une meilleure justice sociale au
bénéfice des plus fragiles à ramener la
confiance parmi celles et ceux qui se
sentaient
ignorées abandonnés madame la ministre
pour toutes ces raisons mon groupe
apportera ses voix dans sa très large
majorité à cette loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
écologiste la parole est à Madame Alina
Chabot
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui une nouvelle fois
est une traduction dans le budget de la
Sécurité sociale du pacte de
responsabilité qui définit le cap
économique voulu par le gouvernement
alléger le coût du travail pour relancer
l'activité
si nous partageons Madame et Monsieur le
Ministre votre volonté de diminuer la
dette de la sécurité sociale pour
assurer la pérennité de notre système
solidarité national nous l'avons déjà
dit la semaine dernière c'est un enjeu
essentiel pour les générations futures
nous ne partageons pas la manière dont
vous avez choisi de le faire et nous
craignons que les mesures proposées dans
ce plfsr ni hypothèque l'avenir de la
sécurité sociale même si quelques
mesures viennent de nous être annoncés
en effet rien ne garantit que les 41
milliards d'euros accordés au total aux
entreprises ne seront utilisées pour
créer de nouveaux emplois car il n'y a
pas de conditionnalités posées j'ai bien
entendu que vous espériez des des
contreparties qu'elles étaient
souhaitées qu'il y aurait un contrôle
dans quelques années il nous semble que
il faudrait que cette conditionnalité
soit organisée et posée
pour financer ces allègements de charge
le gouvernement fait le choix de réduire
la dépense publique du 50 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2017 il y a là tout
d'abord un paradoxe comment reconnaître
que la santé la justice l'action sociale
ont besoin de moyens
de poste supplémentaires et en même
temps annoncé un plan d'économie de la
dépense publique aussi importante
comment justifier d'autre part que les
efforts demandaient au plus modestes
soit plus important que ceux demandés
aux entreprises qui plus est comme je
disais sans contrepartie claire
et nous ne sommes pas les seuls à faire
cette analyse puisque selon la direction
du Trésor les mesures du pacte devraient
générer 190 000 emplois et 0,6 points de
croissance cumulés à horizon 2017 mais
que 50 milliards d'économies par
ailleurs devraient engendrer à la même
échéance la suppression 250 000 emplois
et une baisse de croissance de 1,4 point
cumulés alors nous considérons donc la
logique à l'oeuvre dans ce plfsr n'est
pas équitable qu'elle n'est qu'elle
n'est pas équilibrée et nous avons
proposé plutôt dans les amendements que
nous portions d'autres pistes soutenir
les secteurs économiques porteurs
d'avenir comme ceux de la transition
énergétique écologiste comme certains
services comme d'autres filières
industrielles encourager les
comportements vertueux et innovants des
entreprises par des incitations ciblées
responsables tout en garantissant la
justice sociale par des contributions
progressives dans ces communications le
gouvernement annonce clairement vouloir
soutenir les plus modestes mais pour
agir vraiment leur faveur nous avons
proposé un salon de choses et ont
proposé l'instauration du CSG
progressive pour réduire l'impact
négatif des allègements de charge sur
les basses salaires nous avons proposé
des critères de conditionnalités comme
le contrat durée déterminé ou le contrat
à temps complet pour lutter plus
efficacement contre le chômage nous
avons proposé la réduction de
cotisations sociales de 500 euros par
apprenti et l'ouverture ou en tout cas
la réflexion la mise en route d'une
réflexion sur des dispositifs d'emploi
d'avenir pour les chômeurs longueurés
des dispositifs similaires au
dispositifs emplois d'avenir pour
l'exonération de l'acier 3S nous allons
proposer que que l'allègement bénéficie
aux entreprises qui communiquent sur
leur politique de salaire de dividendes
d'optimisation sociale voilà alors
d'autre part pour faire des économies
durables et sociales nous avons
également proposé d'augmenter les
dépenses
d'investissement dans dans l'accès à la
santé ces dépenses qui permettent à
court un moyen à long terme de faire des
économies
par exemple en mettant en oeuvre
rapidement des mesures de simplification
de l'accès aux droits parce qu'en
s'attaquant aux obstacles qui qui
constituent ce parcours du combattant de
l'accès aux droits aux droits aux soins
notamment pour les plus modestes on
améliore en effet l'état de santé
globale de la population qui dégage
finalement des économies parce que
diminue les dépenses de santé et parce
que ça allège de surcroît la charge de
travail de ce qui instruit des dossiers
dans les CPAM par exemple et donc ça
provoque des économies de coûts de
gestion
vous en conviendrez madame monsieur le
ministre les écologistes n'ont pas
manqué de faire des propositions
constructives au cours de l'examen de ce
budget rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale
à la fois pour rendre efficace les aides
aux entreprises et pour alléger les
dépenses d'assurance maladie nous
regrettons qu'aucune de ces propositions
n'a été retenue que les échanges sur nos
amendements et parfois étaient aussi
bref nous regrettons par exemple que
l'amendement déposait à notre initiative
que le Sénat avait adopté sur le tabac
avec avis favorable du rapporteur était
supprimés par une seconde déliracle
délibération un vote bloqué mesure qui
ne se justifiait pas à nos œufs à nos
yeux cet amendement avait je le rappelle
un triple objectif améliorer les
finances publiques en augmentant les
ressources fiscales favoriser la
politique de santé publique de lutte
contre le tabagisme en diminuant les
trafics réussite qui contrecarne cette
politique et puis aussi favoriser les
petits commerces de vente de tabac que
par ailleurs d'ailleurs on est par des
autres publics puisqu'ils sont en
difficulté et puis je pour terminer je
dirais un mot d'un amendement que nous
n'avons d'ailleurs pas pu ni proposer ni
défendre
c'est celui qui concerne le gardasile
moi je dirais tout simplement que les
porteurs de cet amendement ne sont pas
hostiles à la vaccination en général
qu'une mélange pas tout nous ne tenons
pas des propos ou des raisonnements au
moyenâgeux ou obscurantistes simplement
les porteurs d'amendements estiment que
dépenser 926 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour intensifier
l'utilisation d'un vaccin au sujet
duquel les alertes sanitaires se
multiplient en France à l'étranger dont
l'efficacité n'est à ce jour pas
démontré elle le sera peut-être et qui
pourrait peut-être avoir un effet
contraire au but recherché ce n'est pas
selon nous une mesure de de bon sens et
qu'il surtout quand on décide
concomitamment de gelés plusieurs
prestations sociales pour économiser un
montant équivalent et il nous semble
toujours sur ce point comme moratoire
même
avec une durée limitée serait
souhaitable au moins pour prendre le
temps de vérifier sur ces craintes sont
justifiées et cela serait toujours
autant d'économie faite par ailleurs
pour les finances publiques voilà toutes
les raisons qui font que si le texte
reste en l'état notre groupe maintiendra
se positionne d'abstention je vous
remercie merci madame la sénatrice pour
le groupe UMP la parole est à Monsieur
René Paul Savary
merci
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues sur la
pourtant un président de commission donc
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour
examiner une nouvelle lecture de ce
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 c'est le moment de faire un peu de
bilan que retenir que retenir de cette
discussion sur ce projet de loi
rectificatif d'abord c'est une démarche
exceptionnelle exceptionnelle elle est
sur le plan de la forme sûrement
peut-être pas sur le plan sur le fond
car on ne peut pas parler franchement de
réussite gouvernementale en ce qui
concerne les propositions qui ont été
faites en effet on a pu constater
largement les divisions de la majorité
au niveau du Sénat mais également je
crois à l'Assemblée nationale quand on
prend le compte-rendu des débats des
difficultés bien sûr pour faire adopter
ce texte et c'est normal madame la
ministre vous êtes sur un rien de crête
entre la partie sociale libérale de
votre majorité et l'aile gauche et les
menaces du 3 ou bien elle est les
menaces de votre bloqué sont apparus et
nous avons eu en faire les frais au
Sénat c'est tout à fait l'expression
d'une majorité composite conduite
semble-t-il sans vision clairement
tracée à travers les différents textes
de loi et ça fait maintenant deux ans
que c'est dur deux anxieux et même vos
amis commencent à le dire me semble-t-il
et le Sénat on paye les conséquences au
niveau des lois de finances notamment
rectificatives ou non concernant le
budget général ou le budget de la
Sécurité sociale le Sénat apparaît
maintenant inaudible à cause de cela
alors pourquoi avoir été sur un chemin
de loi rectificatif qui nous semblait
pas indispensable puisque très peu de
mesures concernent l'année 2014 si ce
n'est des mesures pour pénaliser
notamment les personnes âgées à travers
les retraites qui ne seront pas
valorisés et attention madame la
ministre en ce qui concerne ces
retraités ils sont soumis à la double
peine outre la non revalorisation des
pensions il subissent déjà à la
contribution à la Casa sans bénéficier
des conséquences puisque c'est la
prochaine loi de l'autonomie qui doit
faire en sorte que l'on abordera
quelques avancées en tout cas nous
l'espérons en ce qui concerne la prise
en charge du maintien à domicile de ces
personnes âgées notamment les personnes
âgées dépendantes à ce propos
permettez-moi une aparté puisque cette
loi sur l'autonomie s'appuie me
semble-t-il en tout cas de ce que l'on
en connaît notamment sur le savoir-faire
des conseils généraux ce qui montre bien
entre nous que l'échelon départementale
est tout à fait incontournable dans
l'application et la déclinaison des
politiques sociales permettez-moi de le
rappeler
que peut-on donc retenir de ce projet de
loi rectificatif là aussi l'absence
totale de vision du financement des
mesures qui sont proposées la plupart
pour 2015 allègement du cours de travail
diminution des charges salariales
salariales pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat d'un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui peut être contre qui
peut être contre ces mesures vont dans
le bon sens encore faudrait-il afficher
la façon dont elles vont être financées
n'oublions pas que l'État devrait
montrer l'exemple quand il s'agit de
compensation pour les collectivités
c'est toujours à l'euro près et en même
temps que les dépenses
en ce qui concerne les propositions
parlementaires c'est l'article 40 et en
même temps que les dépenses alors là il
y a que semble-t-il l'État qui ne se
sentent pas concernés par cette règle
d'or d'équilibre budgétaire ça méritait
me semble-t-il d'être souligné et ce que
vous annoncez aujourd'hui madame
monsieur le ministre ce que vous
annoncez vouloir donner d'une main il
faudra bien le reprendre de l'autre main
demain nous avons eu un débat
intéressant d'ailleurs sur les
hypothèses de financement de ces
propositions augmentation progressive de
la CSG TV association non déplais
plaises à certains c'est ce qui a été
appliqué pour le la contrepartie du CI
C1 mais peut-être demain faudra-t-il un
jour l'annoncer des cotisations
supplémentaires ou des absences de
revalorisation ou d'un certain nombre de
prestations qu'il a aussi ne seront pas
ou bien des taxes ou environnementales
ou comportementales bref faudra bien
trouver le financement de ces mesures et
ce dès la rentrée alors que pouvons-nous
dire également en ce qui concerne cette
loi rectificative mais non concernant
directement le budget de la Sécurité
sociale mais écoutez la réduction du
financement des établissements de santé
c'est dommage sur la partie
investissement il y a encore un certain
nombre de choses à faire 160 millions
d'euros c'est pas énorme il n'empêche
que là aussi ce sont des investissements
qui ne sont pas réalisés une maîtrise
des coûts de soins de ville oui c'est à
noter il y a maîtrise des coups de soins
de ville qui n'augmentent pas plus que
les prévisions c'est bien mais attention
attention dans les propositions qui vont
être faites notamment de généralisation
du tiers payant faudra faire en sorte de
bien étudier le dispositif de façon à ce
que la responsabilité des uns et des
autres n'aille pas en la dim vers une
dépense supplémentaire mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir permettez-moi de
conclure avec un point bien particulier
bien entendu c'est une mesure de bon
sens qui a été proposé par le Sénat et
je dois dire à l'unanimité une mesure
tournée vers le maintien des personnes
fragiles à domicile une mesure
permettant d'embaucher des personnes sur
le territoire est très souvent en
faiblement qualifié qui sont ces
personnes également susceptibles d'être
embauchés en difficulté une mesure
pouvant répondre à l'emploi local aux
personnes qui se déplacent difficilement
je veux parler bien sûr de la baisse
forfaitaire des charges sociales à
hauteur de 1 euro 50 pour les emplois à
domicile cette proposition portée par le
rapporteur général portait également par
plusieurs groupes politiques
de cette assemblée votée à l'unanimité
par les sénateurs a été refusé d'un
revers de main par le gouvernement
mais accepter par obligation peut-être
mais avec des restrictions à l'Assemblée
nationale
merci pour la reconnaissance envers le
Sénat encore une demi-mesure me
semble-t-il qui fait un bout de chemin
dans le bon sens mais qui va pas au bout
du chemin tous les facteurs sont au
rouge en ce qui concerne l'emploi à
domicile la masse salariale nette de
l'emploi domicile est en recul de
1,6%. le volume r déclaré diminue pour
la 8e trimestre consécutive le nombre
d'employeurs il est passé sous le seul
symbolique des deux millions le
diagnostic est sans ambiguïté le
traitement proposé risque d'être sans
effet c'est le médecin qui parle
soyons pragmatique soit ces emplois sont
essentiels et ils méritent une réduction
significative à hauteur de 1 euro 50
forfaitaires soit ils ne sont pas
essentiels et il ne méritent même pas
une diminution de 75 euros forfaitaire
le coût supplémentaire de cette
proposition 1,50 €
déclarés qui sera bien supérieur à ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous soutiendrons à
nouveau cet amendement pour faire en
sorte que l'ensemble des emplois
domicile puissent bénéficier de cette
réduction de charges sociales
indépendamment des mesures de déduction
fiscale charge à l’état qui dispose du
pouvoir réglementaire d'établir une
liste plus judicieuse des emplois
éligibles et si vous souhaitez consulter
la commission des affaires sociales
franchement n'hésitez pas nous avons des
idées
pour vous aider à prendre ce type de
règlement vous voyez que nous sommes
dans le cadre de propositions pour être
utile pour le sang dans le sens de
l'emploi à domicile et c'est cette
acceptation du gouvernement qui fera que
nous
voterons ou pas ce texte
rectificatif voyez les enjeux sont dans
votre camp je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur pour le
groupe socialiste la parole est à Madame
Catherine Génisson
madame la Présidente est en vous saluant
madame la Présidente je veux souligner
la part importante que vous avez prise
dans le débat qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui mais d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup d'autres débats madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur général et pour vous aussi
je voudrais saluer votre engagement et
puis dire que avec l'ensemble des
collègues ici présent vous avez eu le
tort d'avoir raison trop tôt monsieur le
rapporteur et j'expliciterai mon propos
mes chers collègues
nous voici à la dernière étape de
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour 2014
ce texte important met en oeuvre la
première étape du pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité de la
montée en charge se fera progressivement
jusqu'en 2017
la traduction législative de ce pacte
englobe le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour 2014 notamment pour ce
qui est la fiscalité sur les revenus
modestes ainsi que les sur les sociétés
ainsi que ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative
dont le prolongement des efforts
réalisés depuis deux ans
cet ensemble s'inscrit dans une
cohérence qui comporte singulièrement le
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi cice mais également toutes les
mesures à venir qui accentueront les
allégements de cotisation
ces textes ont pour objectif et
exigences de mettre en oeuvre de
nouveaux moyens dédiés à l'emploi la
première de nos priorités à
l'investissement au renforcement de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et à la
croissance
rappelons une fois encore que ce pacte
repose sur un triptyque qui allie
compétitivité avec la politique de la
fiscalité sur les entreprises qui
abaissent le coût du travail
responsabilité avec un plan d'économie
de 50 milliards d'euros sur trois ans ce
qui nous permettra de respecter la
trajectoire budgétaire des finances
publiques solidarité via les dispositifs
soutenant le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
en première lecture nos collègues
députés ont introduit un certain nombre
de modifications et de précisions je
pense notamment à l'article 2 amender
afin que soit intégré dans le calcul des
exonérations de cotisation certaines
rémunérations liées au temps de pause
d'habillage et de déshabillage je pense
aussi au rétablissement des conditions
de droit commun pour les entreprises de
plus de 20 salariés relevant du régime
de la MSA s'ajoutent le bénéfice de la
C3S qui a été étendue à l'ensemble des
coopératives agricoles lesquelles ne
bénéficient pas du cice
il s'est agit aussi de la mise en place
au sein de la négociation annuelle de
branches sur les salaires d'une
évaluation de l'impact sur l'emploi et
les salaires du pacte de responsabilité
et en particulier des exonérations du
cotisation patronales et du cice
j'évoque aussi l'article suivant amender
afin que le régime social des
indépendants intégrer au régime général
voit son autonomie garantie ou bien
encore l'importance d'un rapport sur
l'impact de la suppression de la C3S
avant le plan le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2017
de même à l'article 9 le gel de
l'allocation de logements familiale a
été annulé en cohérence avec la
suppression de gel des aides
personnelles au logement voté dans le
PLFR enfin une disposition visant à
faciliter la mise en place des contrats
qui devraient être proposés aux
personnes qui bénéficient de l'aide à
l'acquisition d'une complémentaire santé
a été introduite à l'article 11
mercredi dernier notre assemblée à son
tour procédé à l'examen de ce texte
important avant que la première partie
soit rejetée 7 amendements avaient été
voté en premier lieu l'article liminaire
relatif à la programmation et la
gouvernance des finances publiques ayant
pour objet de présenter la prévision
rectifie de cette structurelle et de
soldes effectifs de l'ensemble des
administrations publiques a été rejetée
nous savions tous qu'un risque de
censure de l'ensemble du texte pesé mais
je veux rappeler que ces dispositions
avaient été validées par le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques tout comme les
hypothèses qui le sous-tendent
ensuite un amendement qui abaisse les
seuils minimaux pour le transport
frontalier du tabac manifectaré
magnifique
11 ce avait été adoptée
cela représente un intérêt réel pour la
santé publique pour les ressources
fiscales mais aussi pour les buralistes
de France frontaliers notamment
le second article a aussi fait l'objet
de modifications substantielle puisque
l'amendement proposé par notre
rapporteur général portant la réduction
de cotisations donc bénéficie les
particuliers employeurs à 1,50 € par
heure déclaré au lieu de 0,75 à côté du
1er septembre 2014 a été adopté à
l'unanimité oui monsieur le rapporteur
nous avions tous été des précurseurs
il en va de même pour celui relatif à la
non prise en compte pour le calcul de la
réduction générale de cotisation
patronales de la partie rémunération
affectée à des temps de pose d'habillage
et de déshabillage rappelons que cette
niche sociale représente un montant de
170 millions d'euros selon les
évaluations de la cosse dont 540
millions d'euros pour le commerce de
détails et la grande distribution comme
le rappeler notre rapporteur général ce
montant et marginal par rapport à
l'importance des mesures prévues par le
pacte de responsabilité pour le secteur
de la grande distribution sa suppression
est très loin de neutraliser l'effet de
ces mesures puisque celle-ci représente
plus de 1 milliard et demi d'euros en
tenant compte du cice portant le total
des allègements dont bénéficie le
secteur à 2 milliards 8 d'euros
quant au secteur industriel il ne semble
pas en bénéficier et si des exceptions
faisaient se faisaient jour le
gouvernement s'était engagé à ce que la
disposition telle que votée par les
semblait fasse l'objet d'un examen
singulier lors de prochain travaux par
le mental mais c'est engagement n'a pas
suit l'article 3 qui crée dans le cadre
de la suppression de la contribution
sociale de solidarité à la charge des
sociétés ces trois s un abattement
d'assiette et qui procède à
l'intégration financière du régime
social des indépendants avec le régime
général a été aussi adopté mais la
demande à votre bloqué introduite par le
gouvernement a supprimé ses propositions
vous savez que nous n'aimons pas
beaucoup ce principe du vote bloqué mais
pour autant le débat avec le
gouvernement même s'il a été parfois
ardu a toujours été constructif et
enrichissant mais pour des motifs
parfois divergents la première partie
consacrée aux rochers aux recettes a été
rejetée
certains ont targué du fait que le
baisse du cotisation sociale n'était pas
assez importante allant alors qu'en
charge des affaires publiques pendant
près de décennies bien peu avait été
fait et alors même que notre balance
commerciale s'inscrivait dans un déficit
chronique illustration de notre perte de
compétitivité au niveau international
d'autres dressèrent à réquisitoire d'une
politique qu'il considère comme
d'austérité ce que je récuse notre
politique s'inscrit dans une crise sans
précédent chacun le sait pour autant
aucune baisse de salaire de ressources
ou de rémunération n'a été décidé or
c'est bien cela qui caractérise une
politique d'austérité et puisque nous
parlons de protection sociale en matière
de politique de santé il n'y a pas eu de
mise en cause d'un seul droit d'un seul
remboursement il n'y a pas eu de
création de franchise supplémentaire et
dans le même temps le déficit de la
Sécurité Sociale a pratiquement été
divisé par deux tout aussi important ce
sérieux budgétaire va prochainement nous
permettre de mettre en œuvre une
politique de santé publique digne de ce
nom
je voudrais aussi préciser que durant
une décennie aucune réforme de structure
n'a été engagée comme s'il marchait
allait apporter de lui-même des
solutions comme la crue Madame Thatcher
dont certains frappés par je ne sais
quelle amnésie quand on ravage de cette
politique se réclame aujourd'hui
ouvertement
rappelons que pendant 10 ans la majorité
précédente a toujours fait porter les
efforts sur les plus modestes les plus
fragiles sur le travail et non sur le
capital depuis deux ans la logique est
inversée désormais les réformes de
structures sont mises en œuvre les
efforts répartis plus justement
mais au regard de ces oppositions nous
n'avons pu continuer l'examen de ce bel
effet s rectificatif et dans cette
logique la commission mixte paritaire
n'est pas n'est pas parvenue à un accord
le texte que nous examinons est donc le
texte adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
en première lecture lequel n'a pas fait
l'objet de modification d'ampleur mais
nous actons positivement l'amendement à
l'article 2 portant à 1 euro et demi la
déduction forfaitaire de cotisations par
heure travaillé pour les particuliers
employeurs et vous l'avez confirmé
madame la ministre mais à l'Assemblée
nationale cette mesure a été très
encadrée et si l'on ne peut être
d'accord pour combattre les abus il est
très important de pouvoir croiser la
définition des métiers éligibles et les
publics auxquels ils sont destinés sauf
à créer des des
conséquences contre-productives et pour
la reconnaissance qualitative du travail
des travailleurs et travailleurs à
domicile et je pense que là nous avons
encore un long travail à effectuer comme
cela a été dit pour beaucoup d'entre
nous nous pouvons accompagner votre
travail madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre afin de faire en sorte que ces
travailleurs ces travailleuses à
domicile puissent retrouver comment dire
leur reconnaissance et puissent pouvoir
être déclaré ce qui sera tout à fait
bénéfique pour chacun et chacune d'entre
nous
je voulais vous dire que ce texte de
mobilisation est essentiel il entend
mettre en oeuvre une perspective pour
l'ensemble de notre pays donner de la
lisibilité aux entreprises lisibilité
sans laquelle les politiques
d'investissement de progrès d'emploi
comme toute comme toutes les stratégies
industrielles sont pénalisées
ce PSS rectificatif doit permettre à
l'horizon 2017 de gagner plus de 0 et
demi de croissance de créer 20000
emplois marchands redonnant aux
entreprises les marges nécessaires pour
embaucher innover investir
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas
mettre à contribution les plus modestes
sur la base de valeurs fortes la justice
la responsabilité la solidarité ce texte
met en oeuvre une série de réponses
permettre de soutenir cet enjeux majeur
qui le redressement dans la justice de
notre économie dans L'Homme révolté
Albert Camus écrivait la vraie
générosité envers l'avenir c'est de
donner tout au présent tel est bien
l'objet de ce texte madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre le groupe
socialiste soutient votre texte
merci madame la sénatrice la discussion
générale est close
mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise nous passons donc à la
discussion des articles et sur l'article
luminaire j'ai une demande de parole de
Madame Laurence Cohen du groupe CRC oui
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente mes chers confrères
dans cette émission collecte plutôt dans
cette émission nous sommes toutes et
tous d'accord pour sortir la sécurité
sociale du déficit financier qu'elle
connaît là où nous divergeons fortement
y compris à gauche ce sont sur les
moyens pour y parvenir ainsi avec cet
article luminaire est entériné le fait
que la réduction du déficit public se
fait au détriment des salariés eux-mêmes
notamment des retraités des précaires le
choix que vous proposez et qui irrigue
l'ensemble du PLF RSS sont des choix de
réduction drastique des dépenses
publiques des choix que vous qualifiez
de rigueur et que moi je nomme des choix
d'austérité elle est à l'encontre du
peuple en réalité en réduisant les
ressources de la sécurité sociale vous
allez aggraver le mal c'est à dire le
déficit structurel d'autant que vous
vous appuyez sur un taux de croissance
de 1% que tout le monde conteste
notamment quand on met en perspective la
montée continue du chômage c'est donc
sans surprise mais avec la même
détermination qu'en première lecture que
nous voterons contre cet article
je vais donc mettre cet article linéaire
on voit qui est pour cet article
luminaire
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet article luminaire est
adopté article premier une demande de
parole pour le groupe CRC de Monsieur
Dominique Watrin
qui réduit la part des cotisations
sociales supportées par les salariés tu
ne mesure en fait en trompe l'oeil qui
est plus dangereuse dangereuse que
bénéfique pour les salariés cet article
introduit pour la première fois dans la
loi mécanique de réduction des
cotisations sociales pour les salariés
rémunérer entre 1 et 1,3 fois le SMIC
le gouvernement ne manque d'ailleurs pas
de communiquer sur le gain potentiel
d'environ 500 euros de pouvoir d'achat
annuel que générerait cette mesure pour
les salariés modestes rappelons que cet
argument est utilisé par ce même qu'il y
a quelques semaines s'apprêtait à geler
les allocations au titre des accidents
du travail et des maladies
professionnelles à geler les aides
personnalisées au logement et qui ont
fait voter dans ce même projet de loi en
première lecture un nouveau gel des
pensions de retraite à partir de 1200
euros bruts par mois on sait aussi que
ce petit coup de pouce de 42 euros par
mois sur la fiche de paie mensuel pourra
générer à contrario pour dépassement de
plafond des arrêts ou des diminutions de
certaines aides sociales pour les
intéresser qui pourraient donc y perdre
plus qu'il n'y gagne mais surtout les
cotisations sociales
constituent une part des salaires
socialisés et mutualisés il est donc
tout à fait mensongé selon nous de dire
que leur satisfaction leur production
leur soustraction leur réduction
partielle constitueraient un
renforcement du pouvoir d'achat en
réalité cet article nourrit une fiction
selon laquelle les cotisations ça part
entraînent
raison pour lesquelles les exonérations
devraient comme celles consentie au
patron être progressive en réalité avec
cette logique on peut légitimement se
demander si l'objectif final n'est pas
de préparer un grand basculement du
financement de la sécurité sociale des
cotisations sociales c'est vrai il y en
a de moins en moins vers l'impôt
notamment la CSG le X c'est que la CSG
est une taxe totalement injuste parce
qu'elle est non progressive mais surtout
parce qu'elle est très majoritairement à
plus de 80% je crois supporté par les
revenus du travail ce nouveau système
qui se dessine épargne donc une nouvelle
fois les revenus du capital c'est
pourquoi nous avions initialement
proposé de substitut à cet article une
nouvelle rédaction qui faisait appelle
clairement le choix de l'augmentation
générale du pouvoir d'achat des salaires
car comme les économistes Michel fries
des Joël Maurice et bien d'autres
d'ailleurs nous pensons que les salaires
sont je cite le seul levier qui pourrait
agir pour juguler la récession et
relancer la croissance car en amont de
la crise rappelle-t-il avec pertinence
il y a la baisse de la part des salaires
dans la valeur ajoutée autrement dit la
déformation de la répartition entre
salariés investissement et rémunération
du capital c'est à ce déséquilibre au
profit du capital qu'un gouvernement de
gauche devrait s'attaquer en priorité
n'ayant pu développer cette proposition
car notre amendement était déclaré
irrecevable dès la première lecture nous
ne pouvons que le regretter encore une
fois est voté contre cet article 1 que
nous estimons dangereux
cet article premier qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet article est adopté
article 2 une demande de parole de
Madame Laurence Cohen
oui merci madame la Présidente nous
savons pertinemment que les exonérations
de cotisations patronales ne permettent
pas la création d'emplois ce n'est pas
une posture du groupe CRC c'était là un
fait avéré toutes ces mesures sont
inefficaces et dangereuses car elles
appauvrissent en même temps la sécurité
sociale et par conséquent fragilise de
plus en plus les salariés parmi lesquels
c'est les ceux qui travaillent à temps
partiel sans parler des retraités cette
fuite en avant du gouvernement est une
lourde erreur politique à notre avis et
la question qui se pose est jusqu'où
vous allez céder à Monsieur Pierre
Gattaz là encore aucun procès
d'intention de ma part parmi les 12
propositions qu'il promettent faire lors
de l'université d'été du Medef fin août
permettez-moi d'en citer deux qui ont un
rapport avec ce que nous étudions
libéralisation du secteur de l'emploi à
domicile et de l'apprentissage et
abandons formel de la taxe de 75% sur
les plus hauts revenus un rappel pour
éviter de succomber à ce genre de sirène
je vous rappelle donc mes chers
collègues que si on taxe les revenus
financiers se sont 41 milliards pour la
branche maladie 30 milliards pour la
branche retraite 17 milliards pour la
branche famille de quoi combler vous en
conviendrez largement le déficit de la
sécurité sociale ne soyons ne soyez donc
pas étonnés si nous persistons sur un
vote contre l'article 2 qui assume
malgré tout tous les signaux d'alarme
qui sont au rouge c'est à dire toujours
et encore des exonérations de
cotisations sociales patronales qui sont
inefficaces à court moyen et long terme
merci madame la sénatrice sur cet
article 2
nous sommes saisis de deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 1 qui ne présente
Madame David
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement dont nous avons
d'article 2 nous avons bien entendu la
réponse de madame la ministre mais
nous ne sommes pas
en accord avec cette réponse puisqu'elle
est question effectivement dans cette
exonération de la part mutualisée de la
branche ATMP mais pour nous même la
partie mutualisée de cette cotisation
doit rester de la responsabilité des
entreprises puisque comme vous le savez
ces cotisations branches ATMP
fonctionnent sous un modèle assurantiel
en ce sens qu'elles sont
proportionnelles d'une part à la
sinistralité mais aussi avec une part
commune de donc mutualisée et ces
entreprises payent cette cotisation
d'une part bien évidemment en fonction
de leur sinistralité mais la part
mutualisée sert à la prévention dans les
entreprises et il nous semble important
que même cette part là de la branche
ATMP reste de la responsabilité
de l'employeur alors bien sûr nous avons
entendu que ces exonérations seront
compensées mais nous ne savons pas
véritablement comment et si c'est par le
budget de l'État et bien ils ne nous
semble pas juste que les cotisations de
la branche ATMP soit prise en charge par
les salariés eux-mêmes puisque si vous
compensez par des impôts nouveaux ce
seront donc de l'argent des salariés qui
iront compenser des exonérations que
vous accordez aux entreprises dans cette
branche à TMP c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons maintenu cet
amendement et nous souhaitons le mettre
à nouveau dans le débat sur ce projet de
loi de finance rectificative merci
madame la Présidente l'amendement numéro
15 monsieur des Essarts du groupe
écologiste pour le présenter le
présidente le gouvernement propose dans
cet article une suppression progressive
de la cotisation ATMP et une
compensation par des abondements en
provenance du budget de l'État
nous considérons qu'il y a ici un
message politique important adressé aux
entreprises car celle-ci ne seront plus
tenues de contribuer au financement des
risques liés à leur activité
ce qui est très fortement assurantiel
doit rester financé par des cotisations
d'entreprise et par contre ce qui
s'apparente à des cotisations plus
générales et pouvant être transférée par
la fiscalité doit faire l'objet de
définition plus précise il y a là un
véritable des voix débat à avoir sous la
vision d'ensemble de notre système de
sécurité sociale
le Premier ministre précédent avait
lancé une série de consultations il
voulait remettre à plat à la fiscalité
et il a lancé les assises de la
fiscalité cependant les conclusions de
ce groupe de travail n'ont pas été à la
hauteur des ambitions initiales et il
nous manque toujours un plan une ligne
directrice pour connaître l'évolution de
la sécurité sociale en l'absence de ce
débats face aux incertitudes que soulève
les mesures proposées par le
gouvernement nous proposons de supprimer
par cet amendement cette exonération de
cotisation nous considérons que chaque
entreprise doit cotiser à la hauteur du
risque qu'elle fait peser sur ses
salariés pour maintenir la logique
assurantielle qui est le fondement de
toute la branche ATMP
merci monsieur le sénateur ravi de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général sur ces deux amendements merci
Madame présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
pour cette première partie donc nous
allons examiner plusieurs amendements
qui visent soit à des suppressions
d'articles soit à des suppressions
d'alinéaires sauf cas particulier que
nous pourrons voir la commission des
affaires sociales donnera des avis
défavorables à ces amendements dans la
mesure où leur application viendrait à
déséquilibrer l'ensemble du projet
présenté par le gouvernement donc nous
en avons l'illustration pour
l'amendement numéro 1 présenté par
Madame David et l'amendement numéro 15
présenté par Monsieur de c'est ça la vie
de la commission des affaires sociales
qu'un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs avis
défavorables je ne reviens pas très
longuement sur ce que j'ai pu dire lors
des discussions précédentes et à quoi
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales à faire référence
je vous rappelle simplement que la
cotisation ATMP est divisée en deux
parties une partie mutualisée qui ne
tient pas compte de la sinistralité de
chaque entreprise et puis une partie qui
est moduler en fonction des accidents
effectivement constatés dans les
entreprises concernées évidemment cette
deuxième partie n'est pas concernée par
la baisse de cotisations proposées et
donc il n'y a pas de mise en cause ou
d'affaiblissement de la responsabilité
des entreprises vis-à-vis de leurs
salariés donc avis défavorable madame la
Présidente si madame la ministre je mets
aux voix cet amendement numéro 1
monsieur Savary pour une explication de
vote
merci madame la Présidente nous nous
obstiendrons sur ce vote là parce que je
crois que véritablement cette discussion
ne fait pas partie d'un projet de loi
rectificatif c'est une discussion qu'on
doit approfondir dans le cas de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
dans le cas d'une réflexion globale sur
la fixe
ou des particuliers mais sûrement pas
dans le cadre d'un projet Loire
rectificatif c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne suivrons pas cette
amendement merci Monsieur Savary donc je
mets au bois cet amendement numéro 1 qui
a recueilli deux avis défavorables l'un
de la Commission et l'autre du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet abonnement n'est pas
adopté
amendement numéro 15 qui est un tout
petit peu différent qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient c'est
amendement n'est pas adopté
amendement numéro 2 toujours sur
l'article 2 madame David
oui merci madame la Présidente cette
fois-ci par cet amendement nous
souhaitons revenir sur les réductions de
la part patronale des cotisations
sociales destinées à alimenter la
branche famille en effet en faisant ce
choix le gouvernement fragilise la
branche de la Sécu 7 branche là de la
sécurité sociale pour à terme organiser
une fiscalisation de son financement et
exclure ainsi la politique familiale de
la sécurité sociale une fiscalisation
qui en outre est injuste puisque
reposant pour l'essentiel sur les
ménages alors que son financement repose
actuellement sur une répartition des
richesses créées dans les entreprises et
en effet nous assistons depuis des
années maintenant déjà
à un affaiblissement de notre protection
sociale puisque la sécurité sociale voit
ses principes fondateurs de solidarité
et d'universalité remis en cause le
patronat se désengage du financement de
la sécurité sociale au profit d'une
toute autre logique celle de pour les
plus démunis et de l'assurance pour les
plus riches le prétexte tout trouvé
pardon recule du financement et de
résorber le déficit à court à coups de
mesure libérales qui ne sont qui ne font
en réalité qu'aggraver la situation donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous vous
demandons d'adopter cet amendement mais
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
la présidente madame madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc amendement présenté par Madame
David est un amendement de suppression
de deux alinéas en première lecture
j'avais souligné le caractère universel
des prestations familiales et
aujourd'hui la commission des affaires
sociales donc renouvelle un avis
défavorable à l'adoption d'amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement
numéro 2 qui a recueilli deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté amendement
numéro 20 monsieur Savary
oui merci madame la Présidente donc
c'est l'amendement qui porte sur les
alinéas et 12 et donc sur la réduction
forfaitaire des charges sociales pour
les emplois en domicile nous revenons
aux propositions qui avaient été portées
par monsieur le rapporteur général leur
de la lecture sur ce projet de loi de
finance
rectificatif et qui avait d'ailleurs été
adopté à l'unanimité si une logique
c'est un signe fort qu'il faut donner à
l'emploi à domicile je le répète il est
passé sous la barrière symbolique des 2
millions d'employeurs on ne peut pas
continuer à constater une hémorragie
sans prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour y remédier d'autre part le coût le
coup sera raisonnable il s'agit de 120
millions d'euros qui à travers des
contributions nouvelles sera compensée
d'autre part c'est une mesure à travers
cet amendement de simplification ce que
propose l'Assemblée nationale est une
avancée mais d'interprétation
difficile et ça a été constaté par
l'ensemble des commissaires des affaires
sociales c'est la raison pour laquelle
au titre de la lisibilité ne semble plus
important d'aller jusqu'à cette
déduction forfaitaire d'un euro 50
d'autres parts si les emplois sont à la
limite de l'éligibilité et bien c'est
inutile de faire une
diminution forfaitaire ne serait-ce que
de 75 centimes des charges salariales en
ce qui concerne c'est emplois donc il
est tout à fait logique de poursuivre
sur ce qui a été proposé au Sénat et
donc de soutenir cet amendement qui a
d'ailleurs eu un avis favorable de la
commission mais monsieur le rapporteur
le dira mieux que moi tout à l'heure
merci de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc la commission des affaires sociales
a rappelé la force de son argumentation
qu'elle avait présenté argumentation
donc la semaine dernière elle a pris en
compte également l'amendement présenté
par notre collègue gérardmat avec
l'appui du gouvernement lors de l'examen
à l'Assemblée nationale et après débat
et à la majorité la Commission des
associations a donné un avis favorable à
l'amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur ravi du
gouvernement madame la ministre le
gouvernement donne un avis défavorable à
cet amendement madame la Présidente
j'entends bien la préoccupation qui est
portée par les sénateurs et qui
souhaitent que l'emploi à domicile
puisse bénéficier
de conditions qui soient favorables à
l'emploi de personnes dans la situation
que nous connaissons c'est la raison
pour laquelle au terme de discussions et
le Sénat a joué pleinement son rôle dans
ce débat le gouvernement a considéré
qu'il pouvait avancer pour permettre des
améliorations de la prise en charge
c'est-à-dire des baisses de cotisation
lorsqu'il s'agit d'embaucher des
personnes permettant de soutenir des
publics fragiles nous ne pensons pas je
le dis avec une certaine force qu'il
soit souhaitable d'avoir des dispositifs
qui ne tiennent pas compte de la
situation des emplois à domicile nous ne
pouvons pas avoir des réductions de
charge indiffenciées à domicile
même parler de situation qui peuvent
paraître marginales ou amusantes comme
tel ou telle professeur à domicile nous
savons bien par exemple que si on prend
la garde d'enfant sans la préciser le ou
la prise en charge d'enfance en préciser
les cours particuliers à domicile
bénéficient la baisse de cotisation dans
ce cas-là bénéficie à des organismes que
nous ne citrons pas mais qui sont tout à
fait importants ils ne nous semblent pas
que ce soit la logique à rechercher et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
le cadre de la discussion à l'Assemblée
le Gouvernement a souhaité flêcher les
baisses de cotisation en direction des
publics fragiles pour la garde d'enfants
pour les personnes
âgées en voie de perte d'autonomie et
comme c'était déjà le cas les personnes
en situation de handicap donc vraiment
j'appelle à ce que nous concentrions les
ressources qui sont des ressources rares
en direction des qui en ont
effectivement le plus besoin et qui ont
besoin d'un accompagnement fort à
domicile cela nous semble répondre à la
fois à la préoccupation de relance de
l'emploi à domicile et la préoccupation
sociale qui est la nôtre à un moment en
particulier où nous allons être amenés à
examiner le projet de loi
d'accompagnement du vieillissement de la
population avoir une démarche qui soit
cohérente sur le plan social quelque
chose qui tient à cœur du gouvernement
donc avis défavorable à cette amendement
madame la Présidente si Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Madame Chine
ils sont pour une explication de vote
oui mais merci madame la Présidente je
voulais vous remercier Madame la
Ministre d'acté que c'est grâce au Sénat
que ce débat existe sur le sujet de
l'emploi à domicile parce que ça a
occupé ça nous a occupé très très
largement la semaine dernière et que
nous avions accepté à l'unanimité
l'amendement qui est représenté à
nouveau par nos collègues de l'UMP nous
actons et notre rapporteur nous l'a dit
positivement
la position du gouvernement suite à un
amendement présenté par le rapporteur
général à l'Assemblée Générale à
l'Assemblée nationale Gérard bat pour
autant
nous sommes les uns les autres très
perplexes sur l'application de la fin du
de la disposition qui a été comment dire
adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale dans la
mesure où elle semble quand même d'abord
difficile d'application et où elle
semble par ailleurs restrictive dans son
application ce matin nous avions une
collègue qui nous indiquait un jeune
couple
qui prend quelqu'un à domicile pour
garder ses enfants c'est très bien mais
ce jeune couple qui prend par ailleurs
une autre personne pour s'occuper de la
charge du foyer ça peut être intéressant
pour libérer du temps pour ce jeune
couple pour s'occuper des enfants et je
crois que nous ne sommes pas dans des
situations qui sont inacceptables ou qui
ne sont comment dire critiquables
aussi madame la ministre où nous avons
bien entendu l'engagement du
gouvernement pour indiquer qu'il y
aurait un travail qui soit fait à partir
de cette disposition votée à l'Assemblée
nationale que vous écoutiez avec intérêt
j'en suis persuadé les propositions qui
pourraient être faites d'abord par notre
rapporteur qui sur cette question là
fait des propositions très précises dans
son rapport mais j'allais dire par les
membres de notre assemblée et dans
l'état actuel des choses compte tenues
de comment dire de
l'imprécision quand même de ces
dispositions aux tels que voter à
Assemblée nationale au-delà du fait que
cet amendement a été voté il a été voté
j'allais dire avec quasiment une enfin
une voix d'avance mais reconnaissons que
au sein du groupe socialiste
la majorité du groupe socialiste s'est
abstenu sur cet amendement à la fois
pour être fidèle à l'engagement qu'il
avait pris en première lecture et être
fidèle à son rapporteur mais aussi pour
acter positivement
l'avancée que vous nous avez proposé
madame la ministre
Savary pour le groupe UMP
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
crois que vraiment on a l'occasion
unique de mesurer l'impact de décision
législatives sur l'emploi on l'a bien vu
des décisions a été prises sur l'emploi
à domicile
lors d'un gouvernement de droite et
l'heure du gouvernement de gauche où il
y a eu des suppressions à un certain
moment de la part forfaitaire notamment
et puis la réduction ensuite à 0,75
centimes et on a vu aussitôt la
diminution du nombre d'employeurs et la
diminution du nombre d'heures d'emploi à
domicile je crois que c'est un
une activité dans laquelle on peut
mesurer véritablement l'impact de nos
décisions d'ailleurs ça se verra vite ça
continue à descendre entre ce qui
concerne le nombre d'heures d'emplois à
domicile on verra si nous prenions cette
décision à partir du 1er septembre s'il
y a une remontée des nombreux de
personnes employées et du nombre
d'heures utilisées deuxième argument
deuxième argument
Madame le Ministre
ça évite effectivement le travail non
déclaré mais c'est également nous
semble-t-il et ça a été bien souligné
par Madame Génisson une mesure de
prévention par rapport aux personnes
fragiles
quand elles sont dans un état de
dépendance en ce qui concerne les
personnes âgées c'est trop tard nombre
de facteurs de dépendance sont dus à des
accidents à domicile qui pourraient être
évités les statistiques sont claires en
ayant des emplois à domicile ont fait de
la prévention vis-à-vis du
vieillissement vis-à-vis de la
dépendance il y a une discussion qui se
crée une chaleur humaine des services
rendus une meilleure alimentation de ces
personnes âgées etc qui font que
derrière on recule le moment d'entrer en
dépendance et que c'est quand même
important à la fois pour ces personnes
âgées mais également pour le coup
sociétal donc mesure de prévention
mesure où on me où on arrive à
véritablement avoir l'impact sur
l'emploi c'est la raison pour laquelle
il est important de poursuivre dans la
voie proposée merci Monsieur Savary
monsieur deux Essarts pour une
explication de vote
mais le groupe écologiste va voter
l'amendement qui reprend
l'amendement du rapporteur lors de la
première lecture et même on avait pas
voté les amendements de l'UMPS à ce
moment-là qui était plus important donc
on revient simplement à l'amendement
mesuré
proposé par le rapporteur la fois
dernière c'est surtout une mesure pour
lutter contre l'emploi non déclaré et
les pertes qu'on peut avoir de 0,75 par
rapport à la situation il faut avoir
comment on les récupère par des
personnes qui déclareraient de nouveau
la personne employée c'est ça la
question qui est posée et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement une étude d'impact
aurait été intéressante effectivement
perd 1,50 en faire 0,75 par rapport au
nombre de personnes employées au nombre
d'heures mais on récupère des heures
déclarées donc ça veut dire que ça fait
autant d'argent qui alimente les caisses
de la Sécu donc
là c'est dommage qu'il y ait pas c'est
tenu d'un pas comme l'a dit ma collègue
la mesure aujourd'hui proposée par
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas vraiment
opérationnelle on a du mal à s'y
retrouver et Madame la Ministre quand
vous dites que vous avez écouté le Sénat
on aimerait qu'il soit écouté
différemment pas simplement comme une
sonnette oui on a débattu à l'unanimité
à il se passe quelque chose donc
maintenant c'est le rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale qui va tenir
compte de cette demande de Sénat mais
non il y a d'autres formes de
concertation la meilleure forme de
concertation c'est la CMP ça veut dire
il y a un désaccord entre la proposition
de l'Assemblée nationale et un désaccord
entre le Sénat et il se réunissent et il
trouve ensemble une proposition commune
mais ce n'est pas le Sénat à votre
quelque chose à l'unanimité et à ce
moment-là on fait un vote qui remet en
cause cet amendement et on dit ah mais
quand même à l'Assemblée nationale
tenait compte que au Sénat c'était
l'unanimité pour une disposition alors
curieuse façon de traiter le Sénat par
rapport à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
pas vraiment grave ça peut traduire une
réalité mais à ce moment-là il faut que
l'assumer clairement que le Sénat il est
l'assemblée nation ale divisé par 10 et
au moins ça sera clair donc ensuite on
verra effectivement l'organisation
territoriale que l'on souhaite
l'élection sénatoriale que l'on souhaite
mais c'est effectivement une
considération du Sénat qui est quand
même extrêmement bizarre
si Monsieur deessart la parole est à
Monsieur le Maine pour une explication
de vote
merci madame la Présidente bon je crois
que j'avais tout à l'heure dit en
commission la position que je souhaitais
reprendre par les collègues ma
sensibilité à savoir qu'on suivait le
gouvernement dans son ensemble dans
l'économie d'ensemble d'ailleurs qui a
été suicidé d'une manière très très
longue alors effectivement il y a un
amendement nouveau nous n'a rien appris
de nouveau d'ailleurs puisqu'on avait
longuement discuté de cette affaire là
dans les séances antérieures moi je
crois que il faut pas faire de vilaines
polémique comme ça par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a eu
effectivement un vote qui avait été
donné au niveau du Sénat l'Assemblée
nationale j'insiste aussi comme
certaines d'entre vous à la CMP
l'Assemblée nationale a été sensible à
mieux marquer si on peut dire dans
l'espace les a bien souligné qu'il
n'avait pas de volonté de pénaliser de
quelques façons que ce soit les
personnes fragilisées et c'est pour ça
que dans le cadre de ce qui nous est
présenté nationale il y a souligné
appelé par notre ministre madame la
ministre il y a souligné le fait que ce
seront je dirais moins marqué qui ont
les générations qui seront prises à 50%
pour les personnes handicapées mais
c'était déjà
acté pour les personnes en situation de
fragilité par l'âge
je pense que c'est important et puis
pour les jeunes enfants pour les gens je
pense que là il y a déjà dans ce champ
là des éléments extrêmement positifs
qu'il nous faut soutenir alors on est
toujours devant la même discussion on
retrouve à chaque tournant lorsqu'il y a
des débats de fonds il y a ceux qui ont
va passer loin il y a ceux qui disent on
va trop loin on va pas assez vite les
autres on va trop vite moi je pense
qu'il y a une solution qui est avancée
il y a des discussions qui pourront dans
les projets de loi à venir de finances
d'ailleurs dès la fin de l'année il y
aura peut-être la à ce niveau là des
discussions qui vont encore être
approfondées toujours est-il qu'à la
situation
rectificatif il faut garder l'économie
d'enceinte pour toutes les raisons qui
ont été présentées appuyé en séance et
notamment la semaine dernière par notre
secrétaire d'État au budget je pense que
dans ce cadre là
nous sommes et c'est ce que je propose à
mes collègues de ma sensibilité nous
sommes à même de soutenir le
gouvernement de rejeter cet amendement
tel qu'il est présenté encore
aujourd'hui
nonobstant le fait que notre rapporteur
et je comprends pourquoi hésite et à
titre personnel va s'abstenir moi
j'appelle les autres à voter contre cet
amendement
si Monsieur le Maine la parole est à
Madame Cohen
oui oui madame la Présidente je vous
remercie c'est vrai que en fait c'est
assez compliqué de de choisir je
comprends à le désappointement du groupe
socialiste mais peut-être qu'ils peuvent
s'expliquer dehors
ceci dit je pense quand même si vous le
permettez madame la Présidente je pense
que c'est délicat délicat parce que
effectivement on sent qu'il y a eu une
avancée au niveau de l'assemblée de
l'Assemblée nationale mais que cette
avancée laisse quand même des champs qui
sont non couverts moi j'entends bien les
argumentations de Madame la Ministre et
que je partage c'est à dire cibler le un
public parmi les plus fragiles c'est
quelque chose d'important et en cela
c'est une mesure intéressante en même
temps ces emplois à domicile et c'est ça
qui qui me pose question sont aussi on
l'a vu des emplois qui malheureusement
ont échappé aux déclarations et il y a
eu beaucoup de de comment dirais-je de
ouais c'est compliqué il y a eu
plusieurs collègues madame Cohen et elle
seule à la parole et vous pouvez
demander une suspension de séance j'en
sais rien moi mais bon et il y a eu des
disons parmi ces emplois finalement les
emplois payés au noir donc moi c'est ça
qui me qui me pose qui me pose problème
et je me dis que c'est amendement qui
est reposé aujourd'hui c'est un
amendement qu'on avait mûri ensemble qui
est un amendement qui avait été porté
ensemble et voté ensemble moi ce qui me
semblerait intéressant mais je sais pas
si c'est possible au niveau du Sénat
mais c'est ce qu'avait proposé notre
notre rapporteur en commission quand il
disait finalement qu'il serait beaucoup
plus sage de sortir un certain nombre de
de professions par exemple de dire pas
je vais reprendre l'exemple du
professeur de claquettes etc pas ceci
pas cela de cibler en fait les
professions qui ne rentrent pas de
manière réglementaire dans
ceux qui sont couverts ça ce serait
peut-être quelque chose qui réussirait à
nous à nous rassembler mais je crois
quand même que l'amendement qui est à
nouveau reposé est un amendement qui est
beaucoup plus large et qui prend en
considération la réalité des foyers
d'aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi nous sommes
encore en hésitation dans notre groupe
sur une abstention ou un vote favorable
je ne vous le cache pas madame la
Présidente la dernière chose que je
voulais dire quand même c'est que moi je
suis très intéressé par ce qu'a dit le
ministre équerre en disant qu'il avait
été sensible au débat du Sénat en tout
cas
c'est intéressant de l'entendre
aujourd'hui parce que la foi précédente
lors de la première lecture il avait été
intéressé en ayant recours à une
deuxième délibération et un vote bloqué
pour moi c'est pas un intérêt marquant
pour le Sénat donc j'entends qu'il a
réfléchi la nuit portant conseil merci
madame la sénatrice madame Escoffier
vous avez la parole pour une explication
de merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente je dois dire que je suis
sensible aux arguments des uns et des
autres mais plus encore à ceux de Madame
la Ministre tout le texte et tout cela
le montre est un texte qui se veut dès
qu'il est libre j'ai dit et madame la
ministre l'a dit nous sommes dans un
texte qui veut aller vers de la justice
sociale je crois que ce sont des mots
importants qui veulent restaurer la
confiance ce sont des mots importants et
il faut leur donner là tout leur poids
et toutes leurs forces je crois que
l'amendement tel qu'il a été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale qui a été mûri qui
a été réfléchie donne un cadre un cadre
qui est celui de la raison de la mesure
qui est celui qui explique tout
simplement que ce que l'on doit faire
aujourd'hui c'est favoriser les
populations les plus fragilisées je
crois que les mots qui ont été trouvés
qui sont ceux de ces personnes fragiles
qui vont vers la dépendance qui sont les
enfants en bas âge de la garde d'enfants
désigne déjà des populations qui sont
bien ciblées il me semble que et madame
la ministre s'est engagé que si l'on
fait un travail pour aller un peu plus
au fond l'explicité à travers peut-être
une une circulaire on l'a on se préserve
on se garantit et je crois que la loi
serait là de bonnes applications de
bonnes gestion pour simplement entrer
dans le champ de cette justice sociale
qui va qui doit rétablir la confiance
pour ces raisons-là pour ceux qui me
concernent et ce qui concerne notre
groupe nous voterons contre l'amendement
et nous suivrons la préconisation de la
ministre merci madame la ministre
monsieur la basée pour une explication
de vote
oui madame la Présidente moi je voterai
la main
je pense également que
en 2012-2013 la loi des finances enfin
loi de sur la sécurité sociale on a
peut-être commis une erreur
d'appréciation parce qu'on n'aurait pas
se débat aujourd'hui si nous avions
calés au plus juste nos interventions à
ce moment-là et moi qui préside une
collectivité départementale je suis en
capacité
de mesurer
les glissements que nous savons que nous
avons à l'heure actuelle vers le travail
gris le travail noir nous avons des
13000 personnes qui sont prises en
charge au niveau de lapin
et l'assemblée on peut penser que la
sagesse s'imposera merci Monsieur café
pour une explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente je serai
extrêmement rapide je dirais simplement
que je ne voterai pas cet amendement et
comme je n'ai pas d'hésitation je ne
suis pas hésitant entre l'abstention ou
le vote ou au point un autre vote je
voterai contre cette amendement et
pourtant j'ai fait partie des 343
sénateurs et sénatrices qui ont voté un
amendement similaire qui était présenté
si j'ai bonne mémoire par notre
rapporteur au nom de la commission voilà
j'assume ce vote antérieur mais je
considère que il y a eu une avancée
quand même qui est tout à fait
considérable qui a été acquise à
l'Assemblée nationale que le
gouvernement a fait preuve d'ouverture
et j'ai en mémoire et j'ai été sensible
à l'intervention du secrétaire d'État
Christian Eckert lors de notre précédent
débat bon quand il soulignait quand même
un certain nombre de situations où
franchement
subventionné de tels emplois moi me
poser un problème
les exemples que le secrétaire d'État
nous a cité notre vie je ne veux pas
employer le terme de domestique bon mais
enfin on n'en n'était pas loin
or là nous avons quand même un texte qui
me semble équilibré
qui quelque part exonère
des emplois que je pourrais qualifier
pratiquement d'utilité sociale
et donc moi ce que je considère c'est
que bon on a la une situation
relativement équilibrée je ne connais
pas le coup en fait de cette mesure
j'imagine que c'est 50 60 millions pour
voir plus mais très franchement ce que
je crois c'est que même si je comprends
l'argument sur le travail au noir je
considère que il vaudrait peut-être
mieux se donner le temps de la réflexion
pour voir si le champ qui a été défini à
l'Assemblée nationale peut-être élargie
et à quelles conditions plutôt que de
camper sur une position absolument
jusqu'au-boutiste qui nous vaudra
probablement quelques déboires lors du
vote de la première partie
sénateur
de vote
oui madame la présidente Madame et
messieurs les ministres
alors j'avoue qu'on est dans un débat un
peu surréaliste puisque
encore ce matin en commission on avait
une expression unanime expliquant
d'ailleurs tente aujourd'hui que dans le
passé
les comment dirais-je les erreurs
commises par les uns les autres et la
nécessité de sortir par le haut
ce qui me surprend un tout petit peu
c'est que quand j'entends sur
une partie des bancs du Parti socialiste
si j'arrive à tout comprendre moi
j'emploie les mêmes termes justice
efficacité équité et dans les débats que
nous avons eu ce matin en commission
derrière ces mêmes mots nous mettions le
même vote
c'est à dire soutenir cet amendement
parce que je veux redire ce qui a très
bien expliqué d'ailleurs notre collègue
René Paul Savary c'est que
l'avancée que le gouvernement a fait
c'est d'une certaine manière une demi
mesure qui n'amène qu'à demi résultat
et permettait simplement que dans cette
assemblée finalement je dirais assez
sereine et que l'on dit sage même si
elle ne se laisse pas forcément
cornaquer comme certains le
souhaiteraient nous sommes aussi à
l'écoute en situation de dialogue par
rapport au terrain et aux besoins de nos
concitoyens il a été dit ce matin il a
été dit tout à l'heure que
il y avait peut-être eu des erreurs en
termes de fiscalité de justice et ben le
moment est venu et le moment est
peut-être venu d'aller jusqu'au bout y
compris peut-être pour une fois de nous
retrouver au-delà de nos appartenances
ça avait déjà été souhaité le président
ce matin de la commission puisque
exceptionnellement la présente n'était
pas là mais c'était un président tout à
fait exceptionnel que l'on salue
d'ailleurs puisque il nous a dit qu'il
était une dernière fois Président je
voudrais enfin conclure Madame la
Ministre et Monsieur le Secrétaire
d'étape pour m'étonner quand même de la
difficulté dans laquelle vous plongez
quelque part d'abord votre formation
politique et au-delà les Françaises et
les Français dans leur globalité par
rapport à des mesures de bon sens de
justice et d'égalité
merci la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre équerre
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais juste nous rappeler
collectivement
et ensuite bien sûr l'assemblée sera
souveraine un certain nombre de points
d'abord à ceux qui auraient la tentation
de penser que votre serviteur
ne serait pas un défenseur de l'emploi à
domicile je voudrais simplement leur
rappeler qui cette réduction existe
c'est parce que dans une vie antérieure
c'est moi qui l'ai proposé et sans
travailler nos secrets plutôt durement
négocié avec le gouvernement de l'époque
même si c'était un gouvernement que je
soutenais
ceci c'est du passé
deuxième élément que je voudrais
soumettre à notre réflexion collective
c'est que l'ensemble des allégements
fiscaux et sociaux relatifs à l'emploi à
domicile
représente
représentée en 2012 6 milliards d'euros
6 milliards d'euros
si j'additionne la réduction fiscale et
la réduction sociale
troisième élément que je voudrais
rappeler à votre assemblée
c'est que quand je regarde ce qui existe
dans les pays européens comparables
et à ce titre je vous invite à consulter
le rapport de juillet 2014 de la Cour
des comptes
sur le benchmarking comme ils disent des
de ce qui existe dans les pays européens
7 sur 8 pays européens étudiés nous
sommes le pays qui avons le régime
fiscal et social le plus favorable
et de loin
page 30 non mais le seul et de loin si
nous étions les meilleurs mais dans une
espèce de moyenne on pourrait être fier
là on peut être fier mais on est quand
même un peu dispendieux et je ne
voudrais pas rappeler les excès faut
éviter toutes les caricatures mais je
crois que l'invitation que j'ai que je
nous ai faite collectivement la
proposition que je nous ai faite de
travailler sur un meilleur ciblage parce
que vous avez raison un certain nombre
d'entre vous ont dit
si c'est pas justifié pourquoi y a-t-il
une exonération fiscale parce qu'en fait
là on parle d'un petit bout de la chose
mais l'essentiel c'est quand même
l'exonération fiscale et je pense qu'il
faut j'avais évoqué ce genre de
terminologie mais on peut y travailler
de ce qui est subi et de ce qui est
choisi
sans parler de ce qui est peut-être
nécessaire ou ceux qui peut représenter
des éléments plutôt de confort confort
n'est pas honteux mais doit-il être
financé aussi lourdement par la
collectivité je peux on peut
s'interroger donc je pense que si nous
arrivions à faire ce travail
pour revisiter les choses assez
profondément nous pourrions
collectivement peut-être
peut-être économiser de l'argent c'est
jamais inutile le secrétaire d'État en
compte public qui peut y être sensible
et attaché mais peut-être même déplacer
un certain nombre de financement d'un
secteur vers l'autre
en partie
et donc je crois que c'est ça que nous
devons faire et adopter une mesure
générale sans distinction comme ça pour
être le cas si vous adoptiez cet
amendement nous me semble pas opportun
semblait être un mauvais signal
alors après
est-ce que ça sera créateur d'emploi ou
pas moi j'ai entendu certains groupes
c'est s'exprimer tout à l'heure façon
très précise en disant on est intimement
convaincu que les allaitements de charge
ne créent aucun emploi bon on est
vraiment sur le même sujet moi j'ai pas
cet avis là je pense que globalement les
allègements de charge de leurs études
économiques le montrent
peuvent créer de l'emploi surtout quand
ils sont en destination des bas salaires
ce qu'est le cas enfin dernier point par
d'endettement mais je suis pas intervenu
jusque là
je voudrais quand même vous rappeler
nous rappeler aussi collectivement que
les allègements que propose le texte
pour les salariés vont profiter au
secteur et que tous les salariés à
domicile salarié des particuliers
employeurs vont bénéficier des
réductions de cotisations de salariés
cette fois qui ont été je crois voter
tout à l'heure un des articles alors et
donc il y a là quand même de toute façon
un encouragement et un allègement de la
charge en général celle des salariés en
l'occurrence c'est celle que je viens
d'évoquer donc voilà ce que je voulais
porter à notre réflexion à votre
réflexion collective
sachant que je crois qu'il y a eu une
prise en compte oui de ce qui a été vu
par le dit par le Sénat précédente
lecture bon l'assemblée a accepté de
cibler en lien avec le gouvernement je
crois que c'est pas fermé pris au
contraire au travail KFC se rend prendre
une bonne partie en compte mais aussi
surtout je termine par là une invitation
à avoir quand même un système mieux
ciblé parce qu'on dépense quand même
beaucoup d'argent et sans regarder les
excès qui sont toujours caricaturaux il
y a quand même probablement recentrer
cette dépense merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame la ministre Marisol Touraine oui
je ne veux pas revenir sur ce qu'a
excellent dit mon collègue Christian et
carte je voulais simplement rebondir sur
une interpellation qui a été faite à la
fois par Madame Génisson et par Madame
Cohen tout à l'heure au fond sur le
ciblage et quels sont les emplois qui
pourraient être concernés et va-t-il
comme l'a dit Madame Escoffier y a-t-il
y avoir une possibilité de précision du
dispositif législatif je veux rassurer
sur ce point oui il y aura un texte
d'application puisque la loi appelle des
dispositions réglementaires qui vont
nous permettre de définir de manière
plus précise les emplois qui seront
concernés et je veux redire que non
seulement pour nous la préoccupation est
celle du ciblage mais elle est celle
d'un ciblage social avec en particulier
l'enjeu de l'accompagnement du
vieillissement de la population et de la
prévention j'insiste bien de la
prévention de la dépendance ce qui veut
dire qu'il s'agit non pas de préserver
les emplois concernés à des personnes
dépendantes ou privées d'autonomie mais
à des personnes qui seraient
susceptibles de le devenir si elle
n'était pas accompagnée et donc ce sont
des personnes qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui
en perte d'autonomie et qui pour nous
doit faire l'objet d'un accompagnement
nous pensons par exemple à ce que l'on
appelle en vocabulaire technique que
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent les
Gires 5 et 6 c'est-à-dire les personnes
qui sont en situation de fragilité mais
non pas encore franchi l'étape de la
perte d'autonomie
critique alors même qu'aujourd'hui les
baisses de cotisation ou les allègements
de cotisation sont réservés à des
personnes qui sont davantage concernées
par la perte d'autonomie donc vous voyez
qu'il y a la volonté d'une cohérence
aussi par rapport aux autres textes qui
sont portés par le gouvernement
préoccupations aussi pour les gardes
d'enfants pour je réaliser tout à
l'heure que les garde d'enfants ne
signifient pas ou que l'accompagnement
des enfants ne renvoie pas à une palette
d'emploi trop large de manière qui
n'aurait pas de sens mais concerne bien
le soutien à la politique familiale
l'accompagnement familial à travers des
emplois spécifiques après l'école ou
avant l'entrée à l'école par exemple
donc tout cela sera précisé dans un
texte réglementaire qui peut faire
l'objet d'ailleurs de discussions mais
je veux dire je veux dire que notre
volonté est de cibler les dispositifs
qui sont proposés et puis je terminerai
par une réflexion simplement de
responsabilité financière nous sommes
dans un moment
qui n'est pas simple et on ne peut pas
demander des allègements uniquement de
cotisations sans se préoccuper de
l'enjeu social et d'un autre côté on ne
peut pas nous demander d'avoir des
politiques sociales et demander
d'ajouter des cotisations des
allègements de cotisation aux
allègements de cotisations c'est à dire
que nous nous avons nous marchons sur
deux jambes nous marchons sur la jambe
de la responsabilité financière et sur
celle de la justice sociale mais on ne
peut pas en fonction des
moments se dire c'est tout l'un ou c'est
tout l'autre oui c'est un exercice
d'équilibre oui c'est un exercice
d'équilibre qui suppose qu'on trouve la
bonne manière d'avancer sur ces deux
chemins à la fois et c'est de cette
façon là que nous pouvons progresser et
je crois que le compromis parce que
c'est un compromis moi je n'ai pas peur
de ce mot c'est l'essence même de la
démocratie le compromis auquel nous
avons nous sommes parvenus est un
compromis qui permet de respecter ces
deux orientations ces deux exigences de
responsabilité et de justice sociale
donc j'appelle à nouveau à ne pas voter
cet amendement merci madame la ministre
je vais donc mettre au bois cet
amendement j'ai été 20 j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe
UMP je vous rappelle que la vie de la
commission est favorable la vie du
gouvernement défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 de
notre règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 234 sur
l'amendement numéro 20 nombre de votants
nombre de suffrages exprimés 320 pour
l'adoption 183 contre 137 le Sénat a
adopté cet amendement
nous allons nous en arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 3 toujours sur
l'article 2 madame David non madame
Cohen
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
alors sur l'amendement numéro 3 on est
toujours dans la même logique vous savez
que je vais pas le redire ici donc nous
pensons que les exonérations patronales
ne sont que peu sur aucun effet par
rapport à l'emploi donc simplement nous
attirons l'attention par cette
amendement sur le fait que il s'agit
d'exclure les temps partiels des
contrats ouvrons droits aux allègements
consentis dans cet article temps partiel
qui pour nous sont sont vraiment des
temps qui concernent une majorité de
femmes d'où la proposition de cet
amendement mais je sens qu'il ne
passionne pas les foules
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
présidente monsieur le ministre je suis
un collègue la vie de la commission est
un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur avait du
gouvernement
défavorable merci je vais mettre au bois
cet amendement numéro 3 qui a recueilli
deux avis défavorables de la Commission
et du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 16 monsieur de
Essarts
il s'agit par cet amendement de veiller
à la conditionnalité des exonérations
que nous apprêtons accorder aux
entreprises et en particulier de les
réserver au contrat du travail à durée
indéterminée
le contrat de travail a duré indéterminé
la forme normale et générale de la
relation de la relation de travail c'est
ce que prévoit le code de travail
malheureusement on a constaté au cours
des dernières années un recours accru au
contrat durée déterminé qui sont par
nature précaire d'après la DARES
l'embauche en CDD a dépassé 83% en 2013
lors de la première lecture monsieur le
ministre je précise Monsieur Christian
Eckert qui était là avait déclaré que la
conditionnalité des exonérations n'était
pas un outil adapté contre le recours à
des CDD abusif bon ça a été un peu
démenti par quelques interventions dans
la salle qui disait que c'était dans le
programme du candidat Hollande peu
importe en tout cas
et nous a déclaré le ministre que le
code du travail était l'ultime rempart
contre la précarisation des salariés
nous a même dit c'est le petit le gros
livre rouge qui garantit
le CDI alors Monsieur le Ministre Madame
le Ministre qu'on considère que cette
réponse est quelque peu insuffisante le
cas du travail existe depuis un moment
et il n'empêche pas la précarité de
progresser donc il faut qu'il y ait
d'autres mesures donc si on maintient le
CDI comme norme et dans ce cas nous
devons mobiliser tous les outils de
disposition qu'ils soient légaux avec le
livre rouge le code du travail mais
aussi financier avec un panel
d'incitation pour manier à la fois et la
carotte et le bâton tout en étant
sceptique sur le principe des
exonérations sur les bas salaires nous
considérons que celle-ci doivent être à
minima conditionnel nous proposons donc
de réserver les baisses de cotisation
employeur au recours à des contrats duré
indéterminés ce qui incitera les
employeurs à choisir ce type de contrat
de travail et favorisera la qualité la
stabilité de l'emploi donc la qualité de
vie de nos concitoyens merci monsieur le
sénateur ravi de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
présidente la vie de la commission est
un avis défavorable
avis du gouvernement madame
je vais mettre aux voix cet amendement
numéro 16 qui a recueilli un avis
défavorable de la commission David
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 5 présenté par
Madame Cohen
ecoutez on est toujours sur la sur la
même logique des différents amendements
ou effectivement on souhaite au moins
sortir un certain nombre d'emplois donc
tout à l'heure c'était temps partiel et
là c'était les entreprises en fonction
de l'évolution du nombre de salariés sur
un an donc c'est toujours pour avoir
finalement des des conditions en fait et
pour
séparer en quelque sorte les entreprises
qui seraient vertueuses des autres donc
voilà donc il y a un certain nombre de
conditionnements et c'est un moment en
fait partie merci madame la sénatrice
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
la présidente dans la suite des
décisions précédentes vide la commission
des affaires sociales ça évite
défavorable à l'adoption de l'amendement
avis du gouvernement défavorable merci
Madame la Ministre donc je vais mettre
au bois cet amendement numéro 5 qui a
recueilli un avis défavorable de la
commission David défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté nous en
arrivons à deux amendements
identiques donc en discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 19 madame Escoffier
oui merci madame la Présidente il s'agit
de revenir au texte initial du
gouvernement qui avec un amendement
d'ailleurs qui avait été adopté en
première lecture ici pendant rassemblée
et il s'agissait de rétablir les
allègements de charge dont bénéficient
les entreprises sur les temps de pause
d'habillage et de déshabillage et
d'éviter ainsi d'alourdir la pression
fiscale qu'elle subisse alors j'entends
bien je me rappelle les arguments qui
avaient été développés par le ministre
chargé du budget pour expliquer que ça
s'adressait surtout semble-t-il aux
entreprises aux grands commerce et qu'il
pouvait être dispensé de cet allègement
en réalité nous soutenions que il y
avait d'autres catégories d'emplois qui
étaient aussi concernés et c'est sur
cette base là que nous reprenons le même
argument que celui qui avait été
développé que nous reprenons donc un
amendement qui avait été voté ici dans
cet assemblée merci Madame
la Ministre un moment numéro 22 monsieur
Savary
merci avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements monsieur le rapporteur un
président madame la ministre mes chers
explication en première lecture la
commission des affaires sociales avait
demandé la vie du gouvernement ce moment
considérant qu'elle ne disposait pas la
Commission des informations nécessaires
le gouvernement nous a depuis confirmé
que ce dispositif bénéficier très
largement au secteur de la grande
distribution et dans une moindre mesure
au secteur de la sécurité au vu de ces
différents éléments prédiscution la
commission des affaires sociales a émis
un avis défavorable à l'adoption
d'amendement présenté par nos deux
collègues
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission oui madame la Présidente un
avis défavorable à cet amendement comme
cela a été indiqué c'est principalement
le secteur de la grande distribution qui
est concernée il y a un enjeu d'équité
je veux vous le dire madame la sénatrice
parce que au fond dans deux entreprises
qui verseraient un salaire équivalent
mais ne le paierez pas de la même façon
dans un cas il y aurait un salaire
global dans l'autre cas il y aurait une
rémunération correspondant à une prime
de temps de pause par exemple le niveau
des exonérations ne serait pas le même
ce qui n'est pas équitable vis-à-vis y
compris des autres entreprises et donc
ils ne nous semble pas qu'il y ait là
une démarche à retenir par ailleurs il y
a une contribution des entreprises en
échange de la baisse des cotisations la
baisse des cotisations elle est soumise
à condition il y a des plafonds de
salaires 1,6 fois SMIC pour cette
première phase et il nous semble qu'il
faut en rester là j'attire votre
attention par ailleurs sur le coup de la
proposition que vous faites qui est de
l'ordre entre 150 et 200 millions
d'euros 180 d'après les estimations que
nous faisons et j'attire l'attention de
l'UMP pour lui dire que je ne sais pas
comment on peut poursuivre le travail
d'économie qu'elle nous demande de faire
en multipliant les exonérations aux
économies que le gouvernement propose de
faire ou en tout cas de ne pas engager
donc avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre je vais mettre aux voix ces
deux amendements 19 et 22
identiques ils ont reçu des avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
ces deux amendements ne sont pas adoptés
amendement numéro 6 toujours sur
l'article 2 monsieur wattrein pour le
présenter il est d'accord merci
amendement numéro 7 monsieur Watrin pour
le défendre très rapidement on est ici
dans une logique d'encadrement des
réductions exonération de cotisations
sociales en effet l'article 2 de ce
projet de loi pour effet de réduire les
cotisations salariales à charge des
entreprises et des employeurs mais sans
jamais imposer aucune contrepartie donc
on est ici sur un amendement de reprise
de repli qui proposent que cette
réduction soit supprimée lorsque
l'employeur n'a pas conclu d'accord
relatifs à l'égalité professionnelle
dans le cadre des obligations définies
et que cette diminution soit cumulable
d'ailleurs avec la pénalité qui est déjà
prévue dans le code du travail merci
monsieur le sénateur ravi de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre chaque collègue donc
amendement qui introduit une
conditionnalité la vie de la commission
des affaires sociales est défavorable à
l'adoption madame la ministre
défavorable je vous remercie je vais
mettre au bois cet amendement numéro 7 à
vider favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 8 monsieur
wattrein
cet amendement numéro 8 avis défavorable
de la commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté je mets au
voile article 2
qui est pour cet article 2
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet article est adopté
l'article 2 et donc adopté nous en
arrivons à l'article 3 avec une demande
de parole de Monsieur Dominique batrain
pour le groupe CRC
oui l'article 3 du projet loi de
financement de la rectificative de la
sécurité sociale prévoit de supprimer
progressivement la C3S et d'adosser le
régime des artisans et indépendants au
régime général tout en réduisant d'un
milliard d'euros le montant des
cotisations dont doivent s'accuser les
affiliés du régime social des
indépendants le RSI au titre notamment
de la branche famille on va dire ceci
nous interroge particulièrement d'une
part il s'agit d'une mesure coûteuse
puisque au final en 2017 deux tiers des
entreprises seront exonérées de la C3S
ce qui satisfera c'est vrai une fois de
plus une demande du Medef c'est dire
c'est dire c'est bien d'ailleurs les
moyens et les grosses entreprises qui
seront bénéficiaires de ce dispositif
puisque n'était assujetti à cette
contribution que les entreprises ayant
un minimum
760000 euros annuels de chiffre
d'affaires encore une fois il nous
semble qu'on s'aide ici qui réclamait à
la fois la suppression de la C3S et la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés cet
arbre arbitrage nous semble d'autant
plus problématique que il faut le
rappeler la C3S c'est une contribution
qui a été créée pour instaurer une sorte
de solidarité entre les grandes sociétés
et les commerçants cette contribution
financée en effet le régime social des
travailleurs indépendants et des
commerçants donc tout donne l'impression
que cette opération pour unique objet
d'organiser à terme la reprise de la
dette du RSI par le régime régénéral
alors je le dis tout de suite cette
reprise n'est pas scandaleuse en soi la
solidarité entre les régimes entre les
différents affiliés et pour notre part
souhaita mais cette solidarité ne peut
reposer selon nous sur les seuls efforts
des salariés ni sur un accroissement de
la fiscalisation de notre régime de
protection sociale ni sur une réduction
des droits
la question aussi que je pose comment le
transfert de dette qui sera
impliqué par ce dispositif sera-t-il
financé sachant que comme on le sait
tout transfert de dettes à la Cadès doit
s'accompagner d'un transfert de recettes
généralement assumé par la CRDS et
majoritairement supporté par les ménages
donc bien que favorable à la
construction d'une maison commune des
différents régimes de retraite tout en
rappelant que ce sont les indépendants
et artisans qui d'ailleurs c'était
historiquement opposé une réunion des
différents régimes tel qu'elle avait été
prévue dans le programme du Conseil
national la résistance nous tenons ici à
dire notre opposition mécanisme proposé
merci monsieur le sénateur
l'amendement numéro 9 il est défendu non
madame Cohen
oui très rapidement parce que Dominique
vatrin a dit l'essentiel donc l'article
3 prévoit dans le but de réduire la part
de financement des grandes entreprises
au régime de protection sociale des
indépendants de supprimer
progressivement la C3S jusqu'à sa
disparition totale en 2017 or comme il
l'a souligné la C3S est un mécanisme de
solidarité entre les grandes entreprises
notamment commerciales et les affiliés
du RSI qui peuvent précisément souffrir
du développement de ces mêmes
entreprises il apparaît donc nécessaire
de conserver cette taxe et son
affectation d'autant qu'il appartiendra
demain au régime général de la Sécurité
sociale d'assurer l'équilibre des
comptes du RSI déficitaires du fait de
la suppression progressive de cette
c3ets cette cet article est injuste
puisqu'il fait supporter pratiquement
essentiellement ou en tout cas aux
salariés les conséquences d'une mesure
qui est favorable plutôt au patronat au
patronat donc c'est pourquoi nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
président monsieur le ministre donc la
maman numéro 9 présenté par Madame Cohen
c'est un moment suppression de l'article
3 donc la vie de la commission est un
avis défavorable avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
défavorable donc je vais mettre au voie
cet amendement numéro 9 2 avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient c'est un moment n'est pas
adopté un moment numéro 17 monsieur de
c'est ça pour le présenter
je présente l'amendement suivant les
dispositions de présentes article
s'appliquent aux entreprises qui
publient au sein de leur rapport annuel
la part et l'évolution des rémunérations
et options de souscription versées aux
5% de salariés les mieux rémunérés et
aux 10% les moins bien rémunérés de
l'entreprise par rapport à la masse
salariale totale ainsi que l'évolution
des dividendes par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires aux résultats aux
rémunération et aux investissements de
l'entreprise nous estimons que les aides
aux entreprises doivent être suivies des
faits sur les investissements et sur
l'emploi autrement dit ces aides ne
doivent aller nourrir ni les dividendes
ni les salaires des dirigeants
donc en première lecture je vous propose
une série de trois amendements 22 afin
de garantir une bonne utilisation de ces
exonération de charge
on m'a alors répondu que
l'administration fiscale disposait de
ces données c'est pourquoi j'ai amélioré
mon amendement en proposant que les
entreprises publient ces informations
dans leur rapport annuel afin
avant de bénéficier de l'allègement de
charge nous avons vu que c'était lorsque
c'est donné à l'administration fiscale
le ministère du Travail l'ensemble des
personnes n'y ont pas accès donc il faut
qu'on rentre davantage transparent
l'objectif vous l'avez compris de
demander des contreparties mais aussi de
dissuader certaines entreprises de
reverser l'argent gagné par ces
exonérations directement dans la poche
des actionnaires le rapport annuel est
public et il permettra aux citoyens la
société civile de plus en plus vigilant
avec l'utilisation d'Internet de
vérifier comment les entreprise
utiliseront ces nouvelles marges de
manœuvre puisque le projet de loi
prévoit des aides conséquences
conséquentes aux entreprises nous
considérons qu'il est normal qu'il y ait
des contreparties et en particulier la
transparence sur la création d'emploi
merci monsieur le sénateur ravi de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues donc la
Commission a bien pris acte de
l'amélioration de l'amendement présenté
par Monsieur de cesarmes et à néanmoins
maintenu son avis défavorable merci à
vie du gouvernement
défavorable je mets au bois cet
amendement numéro 17 deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient c'est un moment n'est pas
adopté je mets aux voiles 3 du projet de
loi qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'article 3 est adopté
l'article 4 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'article 4 est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 5 avec une
demande de parole de Monsieur Dominique
Watrin
le 5
porte approbation des prévisions de
recettes et du tableau d'équilibre du
régime général et de l'ensemble des
régimes obligatoires pour 2014 les
prévisions de recettes ont été pour
reprendre la formulation du gouvernement
moins dynamique que prévu en réalité
nous sommes que les recettes ont été
surestimées en loi de financement
initiale comme nous l'avions d'ailleurs
annoncé dans le même temps le
gouvernement précise qu'à l'inverse la
diminution de l'ONDAM et des dépenses
d'action sociale par rapport à la loi de
financement initial conduit à réviser
les dépenses de prêt d'un milliard à la
baisse l'équilibre financier dont il est
question dans cet article nous semble en
réalité extrêmement précaire et demeure
injuste au regard des besoins en santé
des populations et notamment des besoins
hospitaliers alors que des sacrifices
financiers importants sont exigés des
établissements publics de santé puisque
le taux de long dame donc sera
strictement appliqué à 2,4 et que
parallèlement il est demandé à ses
établissements de santé de mettre en
place un certain nombre de mesures ce
qui fragilise leurs équilibres
financiers et je rappellerai que le
ministre le ministre du Budget
consentait à reconnaître que l'objectif
fixé dans le projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale initiale
était pourtant déjà historiquement bas
donc c'est de l'ordre de 800 millions
d'euros que les établissements de santé
seront de nouveau ponctionnés c'est une
semble être une contribution très
importante compte tenu de leur
difficulté de leurs besoins alors que
parallèlement les établissements de
santé privé lucrative bénéficient eux du
CIC et participeront également de la
mesure d'extension des avantages sociaux
sur les basses salaires consentis à
l'article 2 la baisse des déficits de la
Sécurité sociale qui est une chose
souhaitable pour sortir celle-ci de son
déficit et son financement des mains de
la finance et donc bien entendu
souhaitable pour autant cette baisse des
déficits de Me racisme sur une politique
que nous contestons puisque teinter de
beaucoup d'austérité et il nous semble
que au final cela ne pourrait
qu'aggraver les déficits comme je l'ai
d'ailleurs déjà démontré dans plusieurs
des interventions c'est pourquoi nous
nous opposons un certain type merci
monsieur le sénateur je mets au bois cet
article numéro 5 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet article est adopté
article 6 une parole de Madame Annie
David madame la Présidente vous savez la
parole oui merci madame la Présidente
cet article présente donc le tableau
d'équilibre actualisé du fond de
solidarité vieillesse et comme je le
disais lors de l'examen initial cet
article fait le constat de la réduction
des recettes escomptées les dépenses
estimées en loi de financement initial
demeurant stable le déficit du FSV va
atteindre 3,5 milliards d'euros quand la
loi de finances initiale tablette sur
3,2 milliards d'euros
la progression des dépenses de retraite
prise en charge par le FSV le fond de
solidarité vieillesse a donc progressé
de plus de 25% entre 2010 et 2011 ce qui
a pour effet de
ce qui est dû pardon par rapport aux
précédentes réformes des retraites qui
ont eu réforme des retraites pour
conséquence de compliquer l'accès des
plus modestes et singulièrement des
femmes à la retraite en outre cet
article confirme le comme c'est le cas
depuis la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2011 que le fond
de réserve pour les retraites ne sera
abondée ne sera pas abondé en 2014 ses
ressources courantes ayant été
transférée soit à la Cadès pour
contribuer au financement de la reprise
des dettes de la CNAV et du FSV soit
directement au
USB ainsi on peut s'interroger sur le
financement des retraites de la
génération dite du baby boom bien que
c'est différentes réformes et en commun
d'allonger la durée de cotisation des
salariés et donc de la rendre plus
difficile pour ne pas dire impossible à
certains salariés pour avoir des
retraites à taux plein c'est là le seul
moyen de financement de ce fond donc
compte tenu de ces éléments et comme en
première instance nous voterons contre
cette article merci madame la sénatrice
je mets au voie cet article 6 plus son
annexe B qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 6 est adopté l'article 7 plus
son annexe a même vote
le vote
article 8 même vote je vous remercie
nous avons terminé l'examen de des
articles de la première partie la parole
est au gouvernement monsieur le ministre
équerre
oui madame la Présidente
nous avons
observé l'adoption d'un amendement du
groupe UMP sur cette première partie
amendement qui déstabilise
financièrement le solde et
je crois que le gouvernement avait
montré certes à l'Assemblée nationale
mais enfin qu'il avait été tenu compte
de la volonté du Sénat de progresser sur
la question des emplois à domicile si
blanc une mesure sur
les emplois à domicile ayant un
caractère social affirmé et donc madame
la Présidente en application de
l'article 47 bis 1a du Règlement du
Sénat gouvernement demande au Sénat qui
soit procédé à une seconde délibération
sur l'article 2 de la première partie du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale 2014
par ailleurs en application de l'article
44 troisième alinéa de la Constitution
le gouvernement demande au Sénat se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
amendements qui présentent et l'article
soumis à la seconde délibération ainsi
que sur l'ensemble de la première partie
du projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc le
gouvernement demande au Sénat qu'il soit
procédé à une seconde délibération de
l'article 2 en application de l'article
47 bis 1a du règlement la seconde
délibération est de droit lorsqu'elle
est demandée par le gouvernement
conformément à l'article 43 Linéa 5 du
règlement lorsqu'il y a lieu à une
seconde délibération les textes adoptés
lors de la première délibération sont
renvoyés à la commission qui doit
présenter un nouveau rapport nous allons
donc suspendre la séance pour permettre
à la Commission de se réunir madame la
Présidente combien de temps pour la
suspension de séance
c'est un petit air de déjà-vu écoutez il
y en aura qu'un seul amendement cette
fois-ci on se réunit à la salle Victor
Hugo cinq minutes dix minutes je sais
pas 5 minutes le temps
la séance est suspendue
nous passons donc à la seconde
délibération
en application de l'article 44 alinéa 3
de la Constitution le Gouvernement
demande au Sénat de ce prononcer par un
seul vote sur l'amendement et les
articles et l'article soumis à la
seconde délibération ainsi que sur
l'ensemble de la première partie du
projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014
conformément à l'article 42 alinéa 7 du
Règlement nous procéderons de la manière
suivante je demanderai au gouvernement
de présenter son amendement
je demanderai ensuite l'avis de la
commission des affaires sociales et le
vote sera réservé sur l'amendement et
sur l'article soumis à la seconde
délibération
pour le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre équerre oui je crois que la
Présidente je vais me contenter de de
rappeler que le gouvernement souhaite
s'en tenir à la l'amendement qui a été
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale qui tient
compte pour partir je reconnais de la
volonté du Sénat exprimé ici en première
lecture
et donc c'est amendement pour objet de
revenir à l'exonération sur les publics
les plus
ciblées
en majorant la réduction de
0,75 en la faisant passer à 1 euro 50
pour ses publics et pour eux seuls voilà
madame le présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs l'objet de cet amendement
merci
donc l'article 2 avec la commission
pardon excusez-moi monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales a donné un avis
favorable à l'adoption d'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement
donc le vote est réservé sur l'article 2
et je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 7 bis 1a du règlement lorsque
le Sénat n'adopte pas les dispositions
de la première partie l'ensemble du
projet de loi est considéré comme rejeté
et il n'y aura pas lieu de voter sur
l'ensemble avant de passer au vote
unique sur la seconde délibération et
l'ensemble de la première partie je vais
donner la parole à ceux de nos collègues
qui vont me la demander
éventuellement pour expliquer leur vote
monsieur deux Essarts
parce que il y a un air de déjà vu
alors lors de la discussion générale ma
collègue allait marcher un beau a
rappelé la position des écologistes nous
ne pouvons pas voter pour ce projet de
loi de financement rectification
de la sécurité sociale
je vous ai dit il y a un air de déjà-vu
voilà
de ne passons pas que les exonérations
sur les bas salaires malgré les
milliards d'euros distribués est un
effet multiplicateur sur l'emploi
d'ailleurs je souligne qu'un rapport
existe même s'il n'a pas été voté et
qu'il dit que c'est difficile de se
faire une idée c'était un rapport qui
était demandé par le groupe CRC et dont
la rapporteur était madame de Messine et
qui dit il est pas du tout évident de
dire que les exonérations sur bas
salaire soit créatrices d'emploi et la
question qui est posée ce n'est pas la
ce qu'on distribue des milliards de
créer des emplois mais c'est est-ce que
ces milliards aurait pu en créer
d'autres ou plus d'une autre façon
est-ce que par exemple
les embauches voir des maintiens
d'emploi en fonction publique ou un plan
d'embauche massif pour les chômeurs de
longue durée peut-être cela aurait
permis de créer davantage de poste
bon les aides auto-entreprises prévues
ne sont assortis d'aucune
conditionnalité ou garantie que cet
argent aille à l'emploi plutôt qu'aux
actionnaires ou aux dirigeants nous
avions nous avons déposé plusieurs
amendements pour que ces aides
bénéficient uniquement aux entreprises
qui embauchent en CDI ou qui ont une
politique de rémunération responsable
aucun n'a été retenu le gouvernement
prévoit pour financer ses aides un plan
d'économie sans précédent de 50
milliards d'euros jusqu'en 2017 nous ne
connaissons pas les services publics qui
feront les frais de ces aides aux
entreprises est-ce la santé est-ce
l'éducation est-ce l'action sociale
est-ce la justice qui opportant besoin
de plus de moyens seront-ils sacrifiés
sur l'hôtel de l'austérité voilà c'est
pourquoi les sénatrices et sénateurs
écologistes s'abstiendront sur ce projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale merci Monsieur Savary
pour une explication de vote
oui madame la Présidente pour vous dire
notre déception par rapport à l'attitude
du gouvernement
dans ce projet de loi de rectificatif
jusque 2017 il y a 42 milliards d'euros
qui ne sont pas financés les
propositions qui sont faites
d'allègement qui vont dans un sens que
qui nous convient pour la plupart mais
dont on aura discuter le financement
derrière et là on bute on bute pour un
financement de prise en charge de
cotisations sociales dont on verra
la création d'emplois s'il était adopté
et qui met en cause une somme de 120
milliards millions d'euros excusez moi
120 millions d'euros qui seraient
compensés par des emplois déclarés nous
en sommes persuadés
la mesure que vous avez proposé n'est
pas auteur des enjeux en ce qui concerne
ses emplois et on sait que c'est le
problème de notre société l'emploi donc
là on avait l'occasion de véritablement
donner un signe fort et qui pouvait être
mesuré c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous déplorons le passage en force que
veut faire le gouvernement à propos de
cette amendement et nous tomberons pas
dans le piège qui nous est tendu de
voter contre la délibération et bloquer
les discussions nous voulons aller plus
loin dans les discussions notamment ce
qui concerne les dépenses parce qu'il y
a un certain nombre de choses qui sont
tout à fait intéressantes et nous devons
au moins aller jusqu'à l'article 9 c'est
la raison pour laquelle Madame le
Ministre le groupe UMP ne se déplacera
même pas pour ce vote
merci je ne vois pas d'autre madame
Cohen pour une explication de vote
c'est extrêmement bref puisque
effectivement comme l'a dit mon collègue
de Cesars c'est une répétition on a déjà
vécu le même le même scénario je veux
quand même redire que c'est un mépris du
Parlement à chaque fois que le
gouvernement finalement est incommodé
par les débats qu'il y a au Sénat et
bien il a recours à des procédés qui
musaient le Sénat donc évidemment une
nouvelle fois je le dénonce après il y a
du coup des arrangements qui sont assez
curieux nous depuis le début au niveau
de notre groupe nous nous avons la
sincérité de participer au débat et de
dire qu'effectivement ce PLF RSS ne
convient pas parce que il a la même
orientation politique d'exonération des
cotisations patronales et on a d'autres
propositions que l'on met au débat donc
nous restons sur cette posture là là
pour arriver à discuter jusqu'au bout
des articles il faut avoir des drôles de
recours pour finalement que le débat ait
lieu c'est pas à mon avis
digne d'un débat démocratique tel qu'il
devrait se dérouler dans l'enceinte du
Sénat merci Monsieur vanderenberg merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
ce ministre une fois de plus ça on l'a
déploré sur tous ces bancs et en
multiples occasions on voit le mépris
dans lequel effectivement le
gouvernement tient par le nom
c'est déplorable
le 7 procédure qui nous empêche d'aller
plus loin dans la discussion en tenant
compte
de la vie ici du Sénat me paraît
effectivement très très contestable mais
c'est tout le système institutionnel
qu'il faut revoir nous nous y
emploierons certainement mais dans les
années qui viennent
je crois que pour ce qui nous concerne
ce soir
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs notre collègue
René Paul Savary tout à l'heure nous ne
voulons pas bloquer et ça vient d'être
ajouté aussi
noté par Madame Cohen ou par notre
collègue de cessa on veut pas bloquer la
discussion nous on veut pas donner une
image d'un Sénat qui serait comme ça
intransigeant
inintelligent non on veut avancer donc
on va pas prendre par au vote pour vous
permettre de vous déterminer et de nous
prononcer ensuite sur les articles de 9
et suivants c'est à dire sur la partie
dépenses du texte
merci monsieur le sénateur je vais
mettre au bois
cette cet amendement et elle l'ensemble
de la première partie j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par les
groupes UMP et socialistes sur l'article
de modifier par l'amendement du
Gouvernement soumis à seconde
délibération et l'ensemble de la
première partie il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
ça ne demande à voter donc le scrutin
iclo et j'invite les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement du scrutin
je vous donne le résultat du scrutin
numéro 235 sur l'article 2 modifié par
l'amendement du Gouvernement soumis à
seconde délibération et sur l'ensemble
de la première partie du projet de loi
de financement rectificative de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 nombre de
votants 179 nombre de suffrages exprimés
165 pour l'adoption 142 contre 23 le
Sénat a adopté